हेलो
एवरीवन एंड फर्स्ट ऑफ ऑल गुड इवनिंग टू
ऑल सबको मेरी आवाज सुनाई दे रही है
एवरीवन लाउड एंड
क्लियर बताइए
ओके थैंक यू एवरीवन थैंक यू थैंक
यू देर ओनली 25
स्टूडेंट पोर्ट फॉरवर्डिंग इसका पार्ट
नहीं है आपके कोर्स का य नेटवर्किंग की
क्लास नहीं है अभी तो मेरा फोकस रहेगा
मेरे कोर्स के ऊपर वैसे आप पोर्ट फोर्डिंग
यहां पर
अगर मैं आपको नोट्स प्रोवाइड कर रहा हूं
तो शायद आपको नोट्स बनाने की जरूरत ही
नहीं
है कंचन कुमार क्या पूछना चाह रहे हो आप
कि सर मोबाइल में वर्क करेंगे या नहीं
क्या वर्क करेंगे आई डोंट नो
ओके या
श्यर चलो एक मिनट थोड़ा सा वेट कर दो मिनट
का समय दीजिए मुझे मतलब कि थोड़ा सा वेट
करते हैं अभी ओनली 38 स्टूडेंट हुए हैं तो
प्लीज दो मिनट और वेट करते हैं कि एटलीस्ट
50 तो हो जाए मैं 100 की एक्सपेक्टेशन
रखता था आप लोगों से लेकिन 50 के लिए भी
एक्सपेक्टेशन मुश्किल हो गई आप लोग
क्योंकि मैं आपको एक अच्छा कोर्स पढ़ा रहा
हूं आपके लाखों रुपए बचवा रहा
हूं और आप मेरे को सिफ 100 स्टूडेंट लाइव
नहीं भेज आ सकते तो सेम ऑन यू गाइस नॉट मी
सेम ऑन यू
नहीं मोबाइल में नहीं
करेंगे क्योंकि इतने स्टूडेंट है पता नहीं
या तो
सबको नॉलेज है या सबको आता है कि बेसिक
कोर्स तो वह कर लेंगे तो लिटरली मैं आपको
बता रहा हूं कि जैसे जैसे कोर्स में आगे
बढ़ेंगे हम यह ऐसा कोर्स है कहीं पर भी
नहीं है पेड में भी आपको क्या है कि इस
तरीके से नहीं डिलीवर किया जाएगा जिस
तरीके से मैं फ्री में डिलीवर कर रहा हूं
पेड
क्वालिटी क्योंकि वह चीजें सिखाऊंगा आपको
जो शायद पेड में सिखाते हैं न ज्यादा पैसे
लेने के बावजूद
जहां पर आप बोलते हो जिसके मोस्ट पॉपुलर
सर्टिफिकेट जिनकी आप बात करते हो कि सर
मुझे यह सीच करना वो करना है अगर उस परे
भी जाओगे तो उस परे भी जिस तरीके से मैं
डिलीवर करने वाला हूं आपको और जिस तरीके
की क्वालिटी रहेगी और जिस तरीके से उसको
पढ़ाया जाएगा नहीं है उस परे भी
हां पवन सही बोला आपने कुछ लोगों को फ्री
वाला माहौल पसंद नहीं आता सही सही बात
बोली आपने बिल्कुल
अभी आपको अगर पेन टेस्टिंग सीखनी है सीखने
के के लिए तो linbo3
यस दीपांशु सही बोला
आपने चलो दे ओनली 40 स्टूडेंट 48 स्टूडेंट
और स्टिल आई एम नॉट
हैप्पी मुझे नहीं पता कि आप किस तरीके
से सोच रहे हो क्लास के बारे में कोर्स के
बारे में बट इस तरह की अपॉर्चुनिटी मुझे
मिलती तो मैं वेट करता कि नेक्स्ट सेशन कब
आएगा कब आएगा और मैं तब तक उसके बारे में
इतने रिसोर्स फाइंड आउट करता जो भी पढ़ाया
है मतलब टोटली फोकस करता है एक सिंगल
क्लास मिस नहीं करता और प्रैक्टिस प
प्रैक्टिस करता
चलो मैं आपको बता देता हूं नोटस रिलेटेड
सबका सवाल रहता है सर नोट्स हमें कैसे
मिलेंगे तो देखिए कि डे फोनिक्स अकेडमी ने
आपके लिए कुछ सलूशन सोचा है आप लोगों के
लिए एक और इनिशिएटिव लिया है कि डीसी
जीएसपी जो प्रैक्टिकल कोर्स है वो तो हम
पढ़ा ही रहे हैं फ्री में में काफी
प्रीमियम क्वालिटी का कोर्स फ्री में पढ़ा
रहे हैं आपको और कंटेंट भी बहुत ही शानदार
रहेगा आने वाले टाइम में अभी भी और अभी भी
और आगे भी रहेगा तो अभी बात रही आपके
नोट्स की कुछ लोग बोलते सें नोट्स बनाने
हैं क्या देखिए जब मैं आपको वह सारे नोट्स
प्रोवाइड कर रहा हूं कि जैसा मैं पढ़ा रहा
हूं व सारे नोट्स में लिखा हुआ है और वही
अगर आपको बनाने थे तो सारे नोट्स में आपको
प्रोवाइड कर रहा हूं दूसरा क्या है डेफ
अकेडमी आपको कंप्लीशन ऑफ कोर्स कंप्लीशन
सर्टिफिकेट देने के लिए बोल रहा है कि
मतलब जैसे ही आप डीसी जेएसपी जो
प्रैक्टिकल कोर्स है ये अभी जो कोर्स इन
प्रोग्रेस है आप आपका जैसे इस कोर्स को
कंप्लीट करोगे तो आप अपना सर्टिफिकेट ले
सकते हो बहुत लोगों का सवाल था सर हमें
सर्टिफिकेट मिलेगा या नहीं मिलेगा
डेफिनेटली आप लोगों को सर्टिफिकेट मिलेगा
उसके लिए आपको सिंपली क्या करना है
क्योंकि देखो अब डायरेक्टली सबको तो
सर्टिफिकेट हम नहीं दे सकते हमारे लिए भी
हेडेक का काम है फ्री में इतना हेडेक का
काम तो बहुत ज्यादा हो जाएगा लेकिन उसके
लिए आपको एक प्रोसेस है एक छोटी सी
बिल्कुल
आप बोल सकते हो कि एक चाय समोसे जितने
पैसे देने के बावजूद आपको वह सारे
रिसोर्सेस आपको मिल जाएंगे और साथ में
आपको कंप्लीशन सर्टिफिकेट मिलेगा जैसे ये
कोर्स कंप्लीट हो जाएगा ऑटोमेटिक मिल
जाएगा और उसको आप क्या कर सकते हो यूज कर
सकते हो तो उसका सिंपल प्रोसेस है सिंपली
आपको क्या करना है ग पर जाना है डे
फोनिक्स अकेडमी फाइंड आउट करना है डे
फोनिक्स अकेडमी यह डेफ की ऑफिशियल वेबसाइट
है इस पर क्लिक करना है देन गो टू योर
अकेडमी टैब अकेडमी टैब में जाना है देन गो
टू डीसी जेएसपी यह वाला जो टैब है व्यू ऑल
के साइड में डीसी जेएसपी प्रैक्टिकल यहां
पर क्लिक करना है तो यहां पर क्या है एक
आपके लिए फोल्डर क्रिएट किया हुआ है डीसी
जेएसपी प्रैक्टिकल सर्टिफिकेट नोट्स एंड
रिसोर्सेस यहां पर वो सारे रिसोर्सेस और
नोट्स मिलेंगे आपको अभी तक डे वन से लेकर
डे एट तक के जितने भी नोट्स थे सारे
पीडीएफ फॉर्म में इसके ऊपर अवेलेबल हैं तो
आपको सिंपली क्या करना है गेट द कोर्स
करना है और यहां पर सिंपली आपको ओनली जस्ट
पे ₹1 और आपको क्या करना है यहां पर अपने
कोर्सेस को अपने जो नोट्स है उनको एक्सेस
कर पाओगे य वेबसाइट के ऊपर भी और चाहो तो
आप अपने जो डेफ अकेडमी की एक प्ले स्टोर
पर एप्लीकेशन अवेलेबल है मोबाइल एप्लीकेशन
आप उस पर क्लिक करोगे अपना मोबाइल नंबर
उसके अंदर इंसर्ट करोगे और लॉगिन करोगे तो
वहां से भी इन नोट्स को एक्सेस कर सकते हो
और जैसे ही आपका और एक और कंडीशन यही है
कि जितने लोगों ने इसको परचेज किया होगा
41 हमें लिए नहीं है ये य आपके वेरिफिकेशन
के लिए है अब जिस जिस ने इसको परचेज किया
है जो जो इसको परचेज करने के बाद
रिसोर्सेस को एक्सेस कर पा रहा है तो उसकी
इंफॉर्मेशन हमारे पास रहेगी तो सफ उन्हीं
को ही यह सर्टिफिकेट मिलेगा जिन्होंने इस
प्रोसेस को कंप्लीट किया और जवाइन कर लिया
जस्ट पे ओनली 41 देके जो 4 है1 है उसको
सिंपली आप जब परचेज करोगे देन उसके बाद
लास्ट ऑ जैसे ही क्लास कंप्लीट हो जाएगी
नेक्स्ट डे यहां पर आपके नोट्स अवेलेबल हो
जाए जाएंगे यह था आपका एक छोटा सा मिनिमम
अमाउंट पे करने के बाद आपको सर्टिफिकेट
मिलेगा प्लस में सारे रिसोर्सेस का एक्सेस
मिलेगा फ्री में भी आपके पास एक्सेस
अवेलेबल से ऐसा नहीं है कि सर आप लोगों ने
इसको पेमेंट में बेसिस पे कर दिया नहीं
पेमेंट बेसिस बेसिकली आपको वेरीफाई करने
का एक तरीका है सो दैट कि हम आपको वेरीफाई
कर पा रहे हैं और दूसरा आपको सर्टिफिकेट
प्रोवाइड कर रहे हैं एक ₹ में आपको अगर
इंडिया में क्या कहीं पर वर्ल्ड में कोई
आपको सर्टिफिकेट दे देगा एथिकल हैकिंग
सर्टिफिकेट तो मैं मान जाऊंगा कोई भी अगर
आपको ₹1 में एक वैल्युएबल कंटेंट वाला
सर्टिफिकेट दे देगा जिसमें आपको इतना
अच्छा प्रीमियम क्वालिटी का कोर्स पढ़ाया
पढ़ाया जाएगा तो उस कोर्स का आपको
सर्टिफिकेट अगर कोई देता हो व भी जस्ट ₹
में ये जस्ट आपके सर्टिफिकेट की कीमत नहीं
है बस आपके वेरिफिकेशन प्रोसेस के लिए है
जस्ट फिर भी आपको लगता कि सर मेरे पास ₹
नहीं है ₹ नहीं है मैं आपको पे नहीं कर
सकता तो कोई दिक्कत नहीं है मुझे
सर्टिफिकेट नहीं चाहिए मुझे जस्ट नॉलेज
चाहिए तो सिंपली आपको क्या करना है देन गो
टू आपको
अपनी लिंकन प्रोफाइल बनानी है मेरी लिंकन
प्रोफाइल अवेलेबल है तो आपको सिंपली क्या
करना है यह रहा यह मेरी लिन प्रोफाइल है
तो एस सेम सेम करोगे तो आपको मिल जाएगा
दूसरा अगर मैं डेफ दूसरा क्या डे फरस
अकेडमी है फॉर एग्जांपल यर सॉरी डिस्कार्ड
डेफ अकेडमी है तो डेफ अकेडमी पर जाओगे तो
अभी मैंने रिक्वेस्ट किया टीम को टीम क्या
करेगी मैं क्या करता हूं हमेशा जैसे ही
क्लास खत्म होती है क्लास खत्म होने के
बावजूद नेक्स्ट डे को मे बी एंड ऑफ द
इवनिंग शाम तक मैं क्या करता हूं एक पोस्ट
एक आर्टिकल लिखता हूं कि मैंने डेट नाइन
क्लास में क्या-क्या पढ़ाया है और उसके
नोट्स किसके फॉर्म में जेपीजी के फॉर्म
में इसके साथ अटैच करता हूं और पोस्ट कर
देता हूं तो बहुत सारे लोग यहां से भी
एक्सेस कर पाते हैं दूसरा भी रीपोस्ट
करेगी टीम भी तो आपको सिंपली क्या करना है
वहां से भी एक्सेस कर सकते हो बिल्कुल
फ्री में अगर आपको सर्टिफिकेट नहीं चाहिए
तो तो यहां पर सिंपली अकेडमी पर जाओगे डिफ
अकेडमी का कनेक्शन देखोगे तो नाउ हियर विल
बी विल
भी मैं मिल जाऊंगा
आपको पीपल्स
ओके तो सर्च करना पड़ेगा अदर वाइज क्या है
ये मेरी प्रोफाइल्स है जो आप देखोगे ये
रही इस पे रिक्वेस्ट भेजोगे तो सिंपली
डायरेक्टली एक्सेप्ट भी हो जाएगा इसको
फॉलो करोगे तो यहां पर आपको फ्री में
नोट्स मिल जाएंगे जैसे कि मेरे यह री
पोस्ट यहां पर पोस्ट एंड एक्टिविटी के
अंदर जैसे कि ये रहा यह मेरा डे एट क्लास
है डे एट क्लास के जो भी नोट्स थे देखिए
मैंने इस पे लिखा है क्या-क्या मैंने आपको
पढ़ाया है और इसके अंदर अगर कोई नोट्स
नहीं था क्योंकि प्रैक्टिकल क्लास थी डे
एट में तो इसका कोई भी नोट्स नहीं था
लेकिन अगर जिसके नोट्स है जिसके क्या
बोलते हैं कि नोट्स है उनको भी मैंने
प्रोवाइड किया हु देखिए ये रहा एक्टिव
इंफॉर्मेशन डे फाइव है डे फाइव पे मैं
क्लिक करता हूं यहां पर देखिए वो सारे
नोट्स यहां पर भी अवेलेबल है अगर आप चाहते
हो कि नहीं मुझे ₹ पे नहीं करना सर मैं
मुझे सर्टिफिकेट नहीं चाहिए तो ये आपकी
मर्जी है हम आपको फोर्स नहीं कर रहे लेकिन
आपको सर्टिफिकेट चाहिए कंप्लीशन
सर्टिफिकेट आपको डेफिनेटली मिलेगा डेफ तो
ये एक छोटा सा इएस ट आपके लिए लिया है डेफ
अकेडमी ने
तो आप चाहो तो इस सर्टिफिकेट को फिर बाद
में यूज कर सकते हो ऑटोमेटिक जैसे कोर्स
कंप्लीट हो जाएगा अनाउंसमेंट हो जाएगी
कोर्स कंप्लीट हो गया डीसीएसपी प्रैक्टिकल
का तो आपको बता दिया जाएगा अब आपको
सर्टिफिकेट मिल जाएंगे
ऑटोमेटिक ओके 65 थैंक यू गाइस और आपको यह
डिस्क्रिप्शन है जो हमारा जो डिस्क्रिप्शन
रहेगा वीडियो का डिस्क्रिप्शन उसमें भी
मिल जाएगा यहां यानी आप वीडियो का
डिस्क्रिप्शन रहेगा उसके अंदर भी जाके आप
उसको एक्सेस कर सकते हो ₹ पे करना है और
आपको वहां पर सारी रिसोर्सेस देखने को मिल
जाएंगे तो किसी को कोई डाउट है तो मुझसे
पूछ सकता है रिलेटेड टू
नोट्स विनोद उसके बारे में सोचते हैं हम
बेसिकली क्या है कि ये कंप्लीशन
सर्टिफिकेट है एक मास्टर सर्टिफिकेशन है
उसकी तैयारी चल रही है जो आपको बिना
एग्जाम के मिलेगा
नहीं लाइफ टाइम एक्सेस है
तो मिश आप आसानी से इसको कवर कर सकते हो
ऐसा नहीं है इसको आप आसानी से कवर कर सकते
हो तो सबको समझ में आ गई
नोट्स हमेशा आपको क्या कि जिसने परचेज
किया उसको ऑटोमेटिक ली वहीं पर नेक्स्ट डे
शाम तक मिल जाएंगे आपको नोट्स क्लास के
नोट्स अपडेट हो जाएंगे उसमें
स मैं
ट ओके ओके किसका क्या डाउट
था एग्जाम भी देख देख सकते हैं सोचेंगे बट
अभी के लिए तो आपको आपके लिए यही
अनाउंसमेंट
है ओके मैं लिंक दिन
का भेज दूंगा आप लोगों को
सिद्धार्थ प्लीज कांटेक्ट ऑन द डे फोनिक्स
टीम ऑन द वेबसाइट वहां पर आप अपनी क्यूरी
डाल सकते हैं और बाकी मेरी टीम इधर है जो
आपकी क्यूरी देख रही है सिद्धार्थ दास
गोस्वामी की प्लीज क्यूरी लीजिए और क्या
इनका डाउट है और क्या परेशानी हुई है
प्लीज उनको टेक केयर कीजिए
चलो क्लास को स्टार्ट करते हैं काफी टाइम
हो गया है तो ज्यादा टाइम वेस्ट नहीं
करूंगा मैं आप लोगों का तो स्टिल मुझे भी
अभी चैट में थोड़ा सा पता नहीं क्या
कंफ्यूजन कि आप लोग सवाल मुझे समझ में
नहीं आ
रहे तो अभी फिर से स्टूडेंट कम हो गए तो
डोंट वरी जिसको जवाइन करना है कीजिए नहीं
करना तो आपको मैंने बता दिया नोट्स आपको
सिंपली जस्ट डिफ अकेडमी पर मिलेंगे आपको
और वहां से आप एक्सेस कर सकते हो ₹ पे
करके आप सिंपली लाइफ टाइम एक्सेस कर सकते
हो दूसरा आपको जो हमारा वीडियो अपलोड होने
के बाद रिसोर्सेस सेक्शन उसके अंदर भी मिल
जाएगा जो यहां पर जो वीडियो होती है
ये रहा जैसे क्लिक लाइव चल रही है तो यहां
पर ड यहां पर भी आपको मिल
जाएगा ओके ये
[संगीत]
फिर से 40 स्टूडेंट हो गए हैं तो नो इशू
नाउ अ डाउट बोर्ड की बात करते हैं डाउट
बोर्ड पर अभी तक किसी का कोई सवाल नहीं है
प्रीवियस क्लासेस रिलेटेड इसका मतलब कोई
भी सवाल नहीं तो नेक्स्ट चलते हैं ठीक है
तो कोई भी क्वेश्चन यहां पर डिस्कस नहीं
किया जाएगा डाउट बोर्ड प कोई मुझसे सवाल
पूछता ही नहीं कमेंट सेक्शन में क्योंकि
अगर उनका रेलीवेंट डाउट होता तो मैं इसको
डाउट बोर्ड पे लेके आऊंगा लेकिन डाउट
बोर्ड के लिए कोई भी सवाल नहीं तो इसलिए
यहां पर नील है आपका ओके तो अभी सेशन को
स्टार्ट करते हैं दे ओनली 20 मिनट जो पास
हो गई हैं तो 40 स्टूडेंट रह गए हैं जो
छोड़ के चले गए सेशन को क्यों
चलो हमने क्लास को स्टार्ट किया था एक्टिव
इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग में ए मैप के थ्रू तो
मैंने यह बताया था कि जब मैंने एक
सिनेरियो आपको प्रोवाइड किया था कि जहां
आपके पास कोई भी इंफॉर्मेशन नहीं थी तो
कोई भी इंफॉर्मेशन जैसे आईपी एड्रेस तक की
डिटेल नहीं थी आपने पेन टेस्टिंग स्टार्ट
किया था देन उसके बाद आपने नेक्स्ट क्या
किया किया क्या जब आपने होस्ट डिस्कवरी की
थी होस्ट डिस्कवरी के दौरान आपने आईपी
एड्रेसस की इंफॉर्मेशन फाइंड आउट की थी
देन उसके बाद आपने पोर्ट पोर्ट स्कैनिंग
किया पोर्ट स्कैनिंग के बाद आपने सर्विस
सर्विस वर्जन डिटेक्शन किया ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम डिटेक्शन किया और फायर वाल के बारे
में थोड़ा डिटेक्शन किया और आईडीए स वेजन
किया तो देन उसके बाद जो आपके पास जो
इंफॉर्मेशन अभी प्रीवियस नेटवर्क से
रिलेटेड यह है आपके पास यह हैकर्स का आईपी
एड्रेस है यह गेटवे आईपी एड्रेस है यह एक
ws2 1668 1888 ये एक और विज मशीन है जो इस
नेटवर्क के ऊपर
192.168 20104 यह एक आपका
किया ड्यूरिंग योर लास्ट एक्टिव
इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग हमारे पास कुछ भी नहीं
था इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग में में जब हमने
स्टार्ट किया था लेकिन जब हमने एक्टिव
इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग सेक्शन को कंप्लीट
किया तो हमने एक नेटवर्क मैप किया खुद से
क खुद से एक नेटवर्क मैपिंग किया खुद से
नेटवर्क क्रिएट किया और रफ आईडिया लगाया
कि ओके इस नेटवर्क प य ये मशीन है तो एक
192.168 222 एक यह विज सर्वर है तो यह स
वि सर्वर 2008 r2 जो हमने देखा था
ड्यूरिंग एक्टिव इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग तो यह
सारी इंफॉर्मेशन हमारे पास कैसे आई ब्लैक
बॉक्स पन टेस्टिंग जब हमने की तो एक्टिव
इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग स्टेप में हमने सारी
इंफॉर्मेशन कलेक्ट की तो अभी हम बात करते
हैं जो एन मैप टूल था एन मैप टूल में हमने
पोर्ट स्कैनिंग सीख लिया सर्विस वर्जन
डिटेक्शन सीख लिया ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम
डिटेक्शन सीख लिया हमने फायर वल डिटेक्शन
सीख लिया उसके बाद हमने आईडीएस सजन सीख
लिया होस्ट डिस्कवरी सीख लिया लेकिन एक और
इंपोर्टेंट जो टॉपिक थी उस रिलेटेड टू यो
आयर वाल ो रिलेटेड टू योर एन मैप वो बच
गया था जिसको मैं सबसे पहले कवर करूंगा
क्योंकि काफी टाइम वेस्ट हो गया हमारा मेन
टॉपिक जो मुझे पढ़ाना चाहिए था वो मैं अभी
तक मुश्किल है आज उस टॉपिक पर पहुंच पाए
मेटा स्लेट प बट व टॉपिक पढ़ाना जरूरी है
ओके
ना तो एन मैप के अंदर एक चीज होती है एन
मैप स्क्रिप्टिंग इंजन एनएससी जिसको हम
बोलते हैं और ये काफी पावर फीचर है ए मैप
का दिस इज द मोस्ट पावरफुल फीचर ऑफ द ए
मैप अब इसके बारे में जानते हैं क्या चीज
है ओवरव्यू लेते हैं एन मैप एन मैप
स्क्रिप्टिंग इंजन एनएससी इज ए पावरफुल
फीचर दैट एनहांस एन मैप फंक्शनल टू अलांग
यूजर टू रन स्क्रिप्ट रिटन इन द लवा
प्रोग्रामिंग लैंग्वेज बेसिकली क्या है कि
एनएससी एक बहुत ही पावरफुल फीचर है किसका
आपका ए मैप का जो उसकी फंक्शनल को थोड़ा
सा और एनहांस कर देता है जिसके अंदर बहुत
सारी प्री रिटन स्क्रिप्ट अवेलेबल है और
वो स्कप स्क्रिप्ट किस में लिखी हुई है
लवा प्रोग्रामिंग लैंग्वेज में दज
स्क्रिप्ट कैन ऑटोमेट सेवरल टाइप्स ऑफ
स्कैन सच एज पोर्ट स्कैन सर्विस वर्जन
डिटेक्शन वनटी एसेसमेंट ब्रूट फोर्सिंग
मालवे डिटेक्शन एंड मोर और भी बहुत सारी
चीजें तो यह स्क्रिप्ट यह सारे काम कर
सकती है इन स्क्रिप्ट की हेल्प से आप क्या
कर सकते हो पोर्ट के बारे में इंफॉर्मेशन
ले सकते हो सर्विस के बारे में जान सकते
हो वटी एस मेंट करते हो या वटी स्कैनिंग
जिसको बोलते हैं वटी फाइंड आउट कर सकते
हैं ब्रूट फोर्स कर सकते हैं पासवर्ड या
यूजर नेम का आईडिया लगाने के लिए उसके
अंदर प्री डिफाइंड जो डिक्शनरी अवेलेबल है
मालवे डिटेक्शन ट्राई कर सकते हैं और भी
बहुत कुछ एन मैप कम्स विद ए ह्यूज
लाइब्रेरी ऑफ ऑलरेडी
क्रिएटेड्रॉअर्नेविगेटर
की कम्युनिटी पर ओके ऑल ऑफ दस स्क्रिप्ट
हैव बीन अप्रूव्ड एंड वेरीफाइड सेफ टू यूज
एंड ऑथेंटिक जितनी भी जो स्क्रिप्ट
अवेलेबल है एन मैप के ऊपर एनएससी
स्क्रिप्ट जो भी अवेलेबल है वो सारी
अप्रूव्ड है वेरीफाइड है उनको यूज करना
सेफ है और ऑथेंटिक है ओके यूज करना सेव
एंड ऑथेंटिक है नाउ अभी बात करते हैं
कि जो ए मैप की जो स्क्रिप्ट है उनको
कैटेगरी में ऑर्गेनाइज किया हुआ है एक
कैटेगरी है उनको अच्छे तरीके से ऑर्गेनाइज
किया जैसे कि ओथ कैटेगरी ब्रॉडकास्ट
कैटेगरी ब्रूट कैटेगरी डिफॉल्ट कैटेगरी
डिस्कवरी कैटेगरी डोस कैटेगरी एक्सप्लोइट
कैटेगरी एक्सटर्नल कैटेगरी फजर इंटर सू
मालवेयर सेफ वर्जन वल्नरेबल ओके एंड ईच
कैटेगरी एड्रेस ज अ स्पेसिफिक टाइप ऑफ
टास्क और फंक्शन टी हर एक कैटेगरी क्या
करती है आपकी कि उसका अपना एक स्पेसिफिक
टाइप है और या जो उसकी फंक्शनल है उसको
डिफाइन करती है जैसे कि मैं ऑथ जो मेरी
ऑथेंटिकेशन कैटेगरी है यह क्या करती है
डिटरमाइंस ऑथेंटिकेशन क्रेड ऑथेंटिकेशन से
रिलेटेड अगर आपको कोई भी इंफॉर्मेशन जैसे
कलेक्ट करनी है एन मैप के थ्रू ए एनएस
स्क्रिप्ट के थ्रू तो वो इस कैटेगरी के
अंदर मिलेंगी ओके जितनी भी स्क्रिप्ट है
अभी एक कैटेगरी की बात करते हैं डिफॉल्ट
कैटेगरी
जो नॉर्मली हम यूज करते भी है तो डिफॉल्ट
कैटेगरी स्क्रिप्ट एग्जीक्यूटेड विद द
हाइन एससी ऑप्शन ओके तोय डिफॉल्ट कैटेगरी
क्या होती है डिफॉल्ट कैटेगरी के अंदर देर
लॉट
ऑफ देर लॉट ऑफ प्री डिफाइंड लॉट ऑफ सेट्स
ऑफ स्क्रिप्ट मतलब कुछ स्क्रिप्ट है उनका
सेट बना के क्या किया हुआ है डिफॉल्ट
कैटेगरी के अंदर रखा हुआ है जिसको हम क्या
कर सकते हैं
डायरेक्टली क्या कर सकते हैं रन कर सकते
हैं एम के हाइन एससी ऑप्शन के द्वारा ओके
अब ये क्या करता है जो डिफॉल्ट जो कैटेगरी
है क्या करती है इट प्रोवाइड यू यूजफुल
इंफॉर्मेशन
विदाउट एक्टिवली इंगेजिंग विद द टारगेट
सिस्टम इन ए डेंजरस वे इन ए डेंजरस वे ओके
यह क्या करती है आपके टारगेट सिस्टम के
साथ एक्टिवली इंगेज तो करती है लेकिन
डेंजरस वे में इंगेज नहीं करती अब डेंजरस
वे क्या होता है ए मैप के ऊपर बहुत सारी
ऐसी स्क्रिप्ट हैं जो क्या करती हैं कि
एक्टिवली इंगेज करने के साथ-साथ आपके
टारगेट के अंदर जो सर्विसेस रन कर रही हैं
उन सर्विसेस के ऊपर क्या करती हैं
वल्नरेबल को एक्सप्लोइट करती हैं ऑटोमेटिक
आपको इंफॉर्मेशन प्रोवाइड करने के लिए वो
क्या है एक डेंजरस तरीका है लेकिन डि जो
डिफॉल्ट कैटेगरी है ये ऐसा नहीं करती ओके
एक सेफ वे में आपके सामने इन फॉर्मेशन
प्रोवाइड करती है यूजफुल इंफॉर्मेशन
जनरली जब हम बात करते हैं एक्टिव फेज ऑफ
इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग की या एन्यूमरेशन की
तो उस उसमें हम नॉर्मली क्या करते हैं कि
वनटी जो इंफॉर्मेशन फाइंड आउट करने के लिए
वनटी को एक्सप्लोइट नहीं करते स्टार्टिंग
फेज में ओके वटी एक्सप्लोइट हम तब करते
हैं जब
हमें आगे बढ़ना होता है सिस्टम को एक्सेस
लेना होता है या हमें कोई इंफॉर्मेशन मिल
ही नहीं रही ओके तो
यह थी कहानी डिफॉल्ट कैटेगरी की अब इसको
यूज कैसे कर सकते हैं यह भी मैं आपको
सिखाऊंगा तो सबसे पहले मैं आपको एक चीज
बता देता हूं सबसे इंपॉर्टेंट चीज है और
शायद आपके लिए टिप्स भी है यह कि वन थिंग
यू रिलाइज इन योर पेनेट्रेशन टेस्टिंग
कैरियर इज दैट यू कैन एक्सट्रैक्ट ए लॉट
ऑफ इंफॉर्मेशन फ्रॉम सर्विसेस एंड इफ
सर्विसेस आर मिस
कॉन्फिन रिवील लॉट ऑफ इंफॉर्मेशन रिवील है
य दे कैन रिवील लट ऑ इंफॉर्मेशन बेसिकली
क्या है कि आप जब भी पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग
की बात करते हो तो आप अपने करियर में बहुत
काफी बार यह देखो कि जो सर्विसेस है वह
बहुत ही ज्यादा यूजफुल इंफॉर्मेशन आपके
सामने प्रोवाइड करती है खास कर के अगर जो
आपके सर्विसेस है अगर उसको मिस कन्फर किया
गया है अगर उसको सही से कन्फर नहीं किया
तो उस टाइम में तो आपके लिए और भी ज्यादा
कुछ सेंसिटिव इंफॉर्मेशन आपके सामने देखने
को मिल सकती है तो एक टिप थी एक ये चीज थी
सो आपको हमेशा ध्यान र रहेगी तो हम
प्रैक्टिकल सेशन पर चलते हैं इसके
प्रैक्टिकल जो डेमोंस्ट्रेट है एनएससी
स्क्रिप्ट का पहले वो देखेंगे उसके बाद हम
अपने मेटा स्लट के ऊपर शिफ्ट करेंगे लोग
आए थे मेटा स्लट देखने लेकिन मैंने एन मैप
दिखा दिया तो इसलिए वो छोड़ के चले गए
क्लास को
अभी मैं मशीन को व कर रहा
हूं नाउ नाउ नाउ दिस इज माय मशीन इज रनिंग
ओके टारगेट मशीन को रेडी कर लेते हैं एक
बार
सबको स्क्रीन क्लियर दिखाई दे रही
है यह
पैरेट ओके तो आई होप सबको क्लियर दिखाई दे
रही है जो स्क्रीन
है अभी मैं आपको बता देता हूं जो एनएससी
स्क्रिप्ट है वो कहां पर अवेलेबल है मैं
आपको बता देता हूं जब हम एलस हान एल देन
यूजर उसके बाद सेयर देन उसके बाद हम देखते
हैं एन मैप एन
मैप एन मैप देन उसके बाद
स्क्रिप्ट स्क्रिप्ट यहा यह सारी एन मैप
की स्क्रिप्ट अवेलेबल है ठीक है जो लवा
प्रोग्रामिंग लैंग्वेज में लिखी गई है और
दे लट ऑफ मतलब बहुत ज्यादा अमाउंट में
स्क्रिप्ट आर अवेलेबल इनको फदर कटेग भी
किया हुआ है जैसे मैंने आपको बताया था तो
यह सार स्क्रिप्ट है जैसे कि मुझे जैसे ये
रहा एचटीटीपी एनएम स्क्रिप्ट है जो
नॉर्मली यूज आपको दे एनम देख एटी एमेशन
करने के लिए एटी एम स्क्रिप्ट एटी एर एसी
और जिनका जो एक्सटेंशन ड एसी आपको देखने
को मिलेगा ओके य यह सारी के सारी
स्क्रिप्ट क्या है आपके जो नक्स ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम्स है उसमें अवेलेबल है जो ए मैप जब
आप इंस्टॉल करते हैं तो सारी की सारी जो
स्क्रिप्ट है ऑलरेडी अवेलेबल है तो इसका
जो पाथ है यह आपका एलएस नल यूजर शेयर ए
मैप स्क्रिप्ट अभी चलो हम बात करते हैं
फॉर एग्जांपल अभी मेरा टारगेट क्या है मैं
ए मैप को रन करता हूं एम
न पी ए ठीक है पोर्ट स्कैनिंग करना है ठीक
है मैं क्या करूंगा पोर्ट स्कैनिंग करूंगा
देन उसके बाद मैं यूज करना चाहता हूं अभी
डिफॉल्ट स्क्रिप्ट को जो डिफॉल्ट कैटेगरी
वाल स्क्रिप्ट थी उसको यूज करना चाहता हूं
लेकिन जब डिफॉल्ट कैटेगरी वाली आप जब
स्क्रिप्ट यूज करोगे तो उसके लिए कंडीशन
यह है कि आपको पोर्ट स्कैन परफॉर्म करना
है अदर वाइज आपकी डिफॉल्ट कैटेगरी वाली जो
स्क्रिप्ट है काम नहीं करेगी तो हान पीएन
मैंने यूज किया फ हान एसएस स्टिल
स्कन देन उसके बाद
हाइन एसवी सर्विस वर्जन डिटेक्शन हाइन
एससी य डिफॉल्ट कैटेगरी स्क्रिप्ट को मैं
अप्लाई कर रहा हूं हाइन प ल
65535 पोर्ट्स के ऊपर ट्राई कर रहा हूं
टारगेट आईपी मेरा 192.168
222 मेरा क्या है जो विंडो सर्वर है यह
मेरा टारगेट है अभी ट
एंटर इट विल टेक टाइम बिकॉज नॉर्मल जो
स्कैनिंग है उससे ज्यादा टाइम लेगा
क्योंकि यह क्या करर एक तो पोर्ट स्कैनिंग
कर रहा है साथ में क्या कर रहा है सर्विस
वर्जन डिटेक्शन कर रहा है और डिफॉल्ट जो
स्क्रिप्ट है आपकी उसको रन कर रहा है और
कितने
65535 पोर्ट के ऊपर ट्राई कर रहा है तो इट
विल टेक टाइम डेफिनेटली इट विल टेक टाइम
अभी कितना हो गया तो 9 पर हुआ है तो इतना
टाइम लेगा ये
यस मतलब मुझे पढ़ाते वक्त डिस्टरबेंस नहीं
चाहिए जैसे मैं खुद भी पढ़ता हूं या
दूसरों को पढ़ाता हूं मुझे डिस्टरबेंस
नहीं चाहिए जब मैं आपको बोलता हूं कि
प्लीज आप अपने डाउट्स अभी पूछे तभी पूछना
क्योंकि मैं चैट सेक्शन नहीं देखता मैं
पढ़ाते वक्त मेरा पूरा फोकस आपको पढ़ाने
पर रहता है कांसेप्ट की डिलीवरी रहता है
क्योंकि मुझे पता है कि आप क्या सवाल पूछ
सकते हो और क्या सवाल नहीं पूछ सकते
क्योंकि आपके फेज से ही गया हुआ हूं तो
मुझे आपकी कैटेगरी पता है कि आप कहां पर
जाकर कौन सा सवाल पूछ सकते हो इस इसका
जवाब मैं पहले ही आपको दे देता हूं तो कभी
भी आपको एंड ऑफ द जो क्लास है वहां तक
रुकने की जरूरत नहीं होती कि मुझे ओ इसका
आंसर मिलेगा या नहीं मिला ऐसा नहीं होगा
क्योंकि मैं पहले वो सारी चीजें सो सोच
चुका होता हूं आपके लिए कि आप मुझसे क्या
सवाल करोगे इस कांसेप्ट से रिलेटेड इसलिए
कभी भी नॉर्मली मेरी क्लासेस में चलो यह
तो य है इवन लाइव कोर्सेस मे रहते हैं जब
मैं पढ़ाता हूं तो वहां पर भी डाउट किसी
के होते नहीं क्योंकि मैं सारे डाउट पहले
से ही सोच कर चलता हूं दिमाग में कि वह
मुझसे क्याक पूछ सकते
हैं नहीं प टीक्स में डाउनलोड नहीं है यह
इसी का बाय डिफॉल्ट मैंने कुछ सेटिंग चेंज
की हुई है डिस्प्ले सेटिंग इसलिए ऐसा
दिखता है
अभी हो गया
हमारा 88 पर
गौरव आवाज कम नहीं है प्लीज आप अपना अपने
साइड नेटवर्क कनेक्शन को देखिए और अपने
साइड अगर ईयरफोन को यूज कीजिए या अपने
आवाज को बढ़ाइए क्योंकि मेरी तरफ से आवाज
कम नहीं
है इट विल टेक
टाइम मुझे चीज बताइए तब तक यहां पर मेटा
स्लट फ्रेमवर्क किसकिस को आता है या किसने
पहले पढ़ा हुआ है या किसकिस को आता है
बताइए
मतलब मोस्टली को यहां पर मेटा स्लोट आता
है देखिए यहां पर देखिए अभी किस टाइप की
इंफॉर्मेशन आपके सामने आ रही
है मिनिमाइज मैक्सिमाइज यह देखिए अब
इंफॉर्मेशन देखते हैं देखो डिफॉल्ट जो
स्क्रिप्ट थी आपकी जो कैटेगरी वाली
स्क्रिप्ट वो रन हो गई अभी यहां पर देख र
इसने
6439 पोर्ट को क्या बताया क्लोज है ओके
पोर्ट 21 टीसीपी माइक्रोसॉफ्ट एफटीपीडी
ओके नाउ पोस्ट 22 ओपन एसएसए 7.1 अब इसने
ट्राई किया है और भी फर्द देखिए आरएस से
यह कौन सी एम यूज कर रहा है आरएस से ओके
पोर्ट 80 माइक्रोसॉफ्ट आई एडीबी सर्वर यूज
कर रहा कौन सा आईस ओके टाइटल साइट डज नॉट
हैव टाइटल ओके माइक्रोसॉफ्ट आस 7.5 वर्जन
यूज किया जा रहा है मेथड ओके पोटेंशियल
रिस्की मेथड ट्रेस देन य जितनी इंफॉर्मेशन
ट्राई कर सकता है जो डिफॉल्ट कैटेगरी की
स्क्रिप्ट के अंदर व सारी इफ आपके सामने
देगा देखो यह आपका 135 आरपीसी 139 नेट
बायस 445 आपका क्या है आपका
एसएमबी नाउ 167 पोर्ट पर क्या जावा आर एमई
अब इसके बारे में हम हमारे पास कुछ और
ज्यादा इंफॉर्मेशन नहीं थी लास्ट क्लास
में अभी देखिए यहां पर आरएमई डंप
रजिस्ट्री मतलब बहुत कुछ इंफॉर्मेशन आपको
देखने को मिल रही है देखो माय एसकल 5.5.2
लॉग माय ए इंफॉर्मेशन प्रोटो वर्जन है
5.52 लॉग थ्रेड आईडी सर्टिफिकेट फ्लैग यह
है सम मतलब कुछ इंफ फाइंड आउट करने की
कोशिश करर आपके सामने देखो यह
रहा पब्लिक नेम माय एल नेटिव पासवर्ड
ऑथेंटिकेशन पब्लिक ने प्लगइन नेम यह रहा
नाउ दे लॉट ऑफ इंफॉर्मेशन यू कैन गेट इट
जो आपके देखिए यहां पर ये रहा टारगेट नेम
क्या है
आपका वेगें 2008 r2 नेट बॉयस नेम क्या है
उसका देखिए नेट बॉयस न्यूमरेशन भी कर दिया
नेट बॉयस इंफॉर्मेशन दे दी वेगें r2 या
डोमेन नेम क्या है वेगें 2000 r2 डीएनएस
कंप्यूटर नेम क्या है यह रहा प्रोडक्ट
वर्जन 6.1 यह रहा सिस्टम टाइमिंग तो चलो
कोई नहीं है नाउ यह रहा एसएसएल तो दे आर
लॉट ऑफ इंफॉर्मेशन दैट यू गेट तो इस तरीके
से आपको डिटेल इंफॉर्मेशन प्रोवाइड करता
है तो वैसे मैं आपको क्या कर करूंगा कि
इंट्रोडक्शन दूंगा एनम स्क्रिप्टिंग इंजन
का और कैसे यूज किया जाता है स्क्रिप्ट को
और कैसे उसके बारे में पढ़ा जाता है बाकी
जैसे जैसे हम क्लास में आगे बढ़ेंगे तो और
आगे बढ़ते बढ़ते एनम की स्क्रिप्ट को यूज
करेंगे तो आपको और भी क्लियर हो जाएगी कि
एनम की स्क्रिप्ट कैसे काम कर रही है
क्योंकि देखो अभी मैं कंप्लीट आपको क्या
करूंगा कि सारी स्क्रिप्ट के बारे में
बताऊंगा तो एक टाइम को का करना होता है
टाइम को मतलब वेस्ट करना होता है इधर
क्योंकि यह पढ़ाना सही नहीं है मैंने आपको
इंट्रोडक्शन दे दिया स्क्रिप्ट को कैसे
यूज कर सकते हैं य मैं आपको बता दूंगा
उसके बाद स्क्रिप्ट के बारे में
इंफॉर्मेशन कैसे ले सकते हो ये मैंने आपको
बता दिया और जैसे-जैसे क्लासेस में हम
एनवे की स्क्रिप्टिंग को यूज करेंगे फरदर
जैसे अभी एन्यूमरेशन करेंगे हम एन्यूमरेशन
में हम ए मैप को भी यूज करेंगे मेटा स्प्ड
को भी यूज करेंगे और अदर कोई टूल आता है
तो उसको भी यूज करेंगे तीनों मल्टीपल टूल
को यूज करेंगे तो उस टाइम प जो जो
इंफॉर्मेशन रिक्वायर्ड है हम ए मैप की वो
भी प्रोवाइड कर देंगे आपको अगर एक्स्ट्रा
इंफॉर्मेशन चाहिए तो ओके तो अभी देखिए कि
इसमें अभी ये इंफॉर्मेशन आपको मिल ग अभी
इसमें मुझे क्या चाहिए था अगर किस रिलेटेड
है मैं अभी अपाचे एचटीटीपीडी अपाचे से
रिलेटेड मुझे स्क्रिप्ट फाइंड आउट करनी है
ए स्क्रिप्ट तो कैसे फाइंड आउट कर सकता
एटी न्यूमरेशन करते हैं वो भी कर सकते हैं
तभी मैं अ लेटेड फाइंड आउट करता हूं मैं
एलस यह रहा ग्रब करते इसके अंदर कोई
स्क्रिप्ट अवेलेबल अचे
की ग्रेप अपाचे
ये रहा अच सर्वर स्टेटस ड एएसी है एडीटीपी
की अचय नेगोशिएशन अभी मुझे देखिए मैंने
ग्रैब तो कर लिया कि ओके यहां पर सारी
स्क्रिप्ट अवेलेबल है किसकी मेरी ए मैप की
और उसके बाद ग्रैब किया कि मुझे अपास से
रिलेटेड स्क्रिप्ट चाहिए
http.sys एक्चुअल में इसका काम क्या है तो
ये भी ये भी देख सकता हूं कैसे ए मैप हान
हाइन
स्क्रिप्ट स्क्रिप्ट उसके बाद हाइन हेल्प
एक ये कमांड होती है इक्वल साइन उसके बाद
ये आपका स्क्रिप्ट का नाम एक्सटेंशन देने
की आपको जरूरत नहीं है आप सिंपली इतना नाम
क्या करो कॉपी एंड पेस्ट कर दीजिए यहां पर
कॉपी एंड पेस्ट कर दिया और हिट एंटर कर
दीजिए आप सिंपली देखिए ये आपको बता देगा
कि
य स्क्रिप्ट क्या करेगी आपको डिस्कवरी सेफ
कैटेगरी की स्क्रिप्ट है यह आपकी अटेंप्ट
टू रिट्रीव द सर्वर स्टेटस पेज फॉर अचे
वेब सर्वर्स दैट हैड मोड स्टेटस इनेबल्ड
इफ सर्वर स्टेटस पेज एजिस्ट एंड अपीयर्स
टू टू बी फ्रॉम मोड स्टेटस द स्क्रिप्ट
विल पास यूजफुल इंफॉर्मेशन सच एज द सिस्टम
अप टाइम अचे वर्जन और रिसेंट एचटीटीपी
रिक्वेस्ट यह सारी इंफॉर्मेशन आपके सामने
प्रोवाइड करेगी तो इसको हम यूज कैसे करना
है तो यूज करने के लिए फॉर एग्जांपल मैं
कैसे करूंगा कि ए किया उसके बाद सिनस कैन
देन उसके बाद सर्विस वर्जन में चाहूं तो
यूज कर सकता हूं चलो सर्विस वर्जन देन
उसके बाद स्क्रिप्ट यूज करूंगा हान हान आ
आई पीटी स्क्रिप्ट अभी डायरेक्टली
स्क्रिप्ट रन कर लेता हूं
चलो हाइन हाइन एस सी आर आई पीटी स्क्रिप्ट
देन उसके बाद इक्वल साइन और स्क्रिप्ट का
नाम मैं पेस्ट कर देता हूं इधर ये रहा
मैंने य पर पेस्ट कर दिया स्क्रिप्ट का
नाम देन उसके बाद पोर्ट नंबर मेंशन कर
सकता हूं हापन पोर्ट नंबर अभी मुझे पोर्ट
नंबर चाहिए तो मेरा कहां पर पोर्ट है इस
पर य अचे वाला पोर्ट हमें फाइंड आउट करना
पड़ेगा तो कहां पर देखा था
हमने दिस इज द अपाचे
अचे हमने कहां पर देखा था
अपने श द अचे
पोर्ट ये रहा 8585
पोर्ट नंबर हमने क्या दिया मेंशन किया 85
85 8585 देन हमारा टारगेट आईपी देन हमारा
टारगेट आईपी एड्रेस मैं थोड़ा सा फास्ट और
कर लेता हूं t4 मेंशन करके देन
192.168
0.22 और हिट एंटर कर दिया मैंने देखिए यह
क्या बता रहा है अननोन सर्विस अननोन है
चलो कोई
नहीं अभी मेरे पास अगर ये अवेलेबल नहीं है
तो चलो मैं एक काम कर देता हूं एनवे स्कन
फॉर ओके के लेटेंसी ओके ओके
ओके चलो अपने आप पता कर लेंगे हिट एंटर
59 यह देखिए अभी अननोन अननोन अननोन अननोन
यहां पर कुछ है इसके रिलेटेड इंफॉर्मेशन
नहीं
है मतलब वहां कुछ रंग इंफॉर्मेशन थी या पा
से रिलेटेड थी तो बट कुछ मिला नहीं इसको
तो इट्स ओके अगर मुझे इसके जगह यूज करनी
है स्क्रिप्ट अगर मैं यूज करना चाहता हूं
एनम हान डायरेक्टली मैं स्क्रिप्ट यूज
करना चाहता हूं अगर मुझे अभी यूज करनी है
डायरेक्टली स्क्रिप्ट कौन सी यूज कर रहा
हूं मैं चलो
इन एस एस हाइन पीएन और यूज कर लेते हैं
पीएन देन उसके बाद हान आन आई पीटी
स्क्रिप्ट हान आन स्क्रिप्ट इक्वल टू देन
मैं अभ यूज कर रहा हूं एचटीटीपी
एनम एचटीटीपी हाइन एनम एमेशन देन उसके बाद
मेरा एटीटीपी एनम देन मैं यूज करने वाला
हूं उसके बाद हाइन पोर्ट पोर्ट मेरा 80
होगा ओबवियसली 80 पोर्ट नंबर 80
देन
192.168 222 अब ये स्क्रिप्ट क्या काम
करती है वो भी मैं आपको दिखा दूंगा देखिए
अभी
[संगीत]
मे बी इट विल टेक
टाइम नहीं इक्वल साइन के साथ भी काम करता
है ऐसा नहीं कि य काम नहीं करेगा नहीं ऐसा
नहीं है तो य पर कुछ इंफॉर्मेशन देखने या
तो हम रंग व ट्राई कर रहे हैं पाथ में तो
इटस ओके इस तरीके से आप क्या कर सकते हो
स्क्रिप्ट को यूज कर सकते मैं बस जस्ट
आपको दिखा रहा हूं देखो पोट एटीटीपी है
एंड एंड यह रहा माय एसकल इधर चलो माय एसकल
से रिलेटेड कोई हमारे पास एन मैप की
स्क्रिप्ट अवेलेबल है तो हम ट्राई कर सकते
हैं ग्रब
करके ऑडिटड एनसी इनो य रहा माय इफ एनसी को
ट्राई कर लेते चलो कॉपी एंड ट द पोर्ट
नंबर फॉर माय एसकल माय पोर्ट नंबर हमारे
पास
[संगीत]
है
3306 एन मैप हाइन एस एस हाइन सर्विस वर्जन
देन उसके बाद हाइन हाइन स्क्रिप्ट देन
उसके बाद इक्वल साइन देन उसके बाद कंट्रोल
शिफ्ट व उसके बाद हम क्या करते हैं यूज
करते
हैं हाइफ
3306 एंड
192.168 ट उसके बाद हाई फन t4 यह
रहा यह रहा माय एसक्यूएल ब्लॉक टू मेनी
कनेक्शन एरर मतलब कुछ एरर क्रिएट हुई है
क्य काफी टाइम से मशीन मेरी अप है क्योंकि
अभी ऑलरेडी लबल मशीन है तो हो सकता है कोई
एरर हो तो इस तरीके से आपकी स्क्रिप्ट काम
करती है अभी मैं आपको एक और चीज बता देता
हूं कि अगर मुझे सर्विस वर्जन डिटेक्शन
स्कैन भी करना है या मुझे और साथ में
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम डिटेक्शन स्कैन भी करना
है और साथ में डिफॉल्ट एन मैप स्क्रिप्ट
स्कैन भी करना है एक ही साथ तो मैं कैसे
कर सकता हूं किसी को आईडिया है ये तीनों
चीज अगर मुझे एक साथ करनी तो कैसे कर सकता
हूं तो मैंने आपको तरीका बता दिया कि जो
एनएससी स्क्रिप्ट है वो कैसे यूज होती हैं
अभ यहां पर आपको आउटपुट नहीं आ रहा या हो
सकता है कि मैं सही स्क्रिप्ट यूज नहीं कर
रहा सही उसके लिए क्योंकि अभी मैं जस्ट
आपको सिखाने के लिए यूज कर रहा हूं जब हम
उस परे टारगेट पर प्रैक्टिस करेंगे या जब
हम लैब्स यूज करेंगे तो वहां पर हम सही
स्क्रिप्ट यूज करेंगे सही तरीके से तो व
आपको इंफॉर्मेशन भी आपको देखने को
मिलेगी यस शुभम ने सही गेस किया तो एंड
मैं 51 एच ट्राई करता हूं मैं देखिए हेल्प
फाइल में देखोगे हान ए इनेबल ओस डिटेक्शन
वर्जन डिटेक्शन स्क्रिप्ट स्कैनिंग ट्रेस
रूट वाट वट ये और भी सारी चीजें काम कर
रहा है ठीक है इतने सारे काम तो अभी मैं
क्या कर सकता हूं सारी की सारी चीजें एक
साथ ट्राई कर सकता हूं मैं कैसे ए मैप
हाइन सिल स्कैन देन उसके बाद हाइन कैपिटल
ए ए का मतलब क्या है मैं ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम
डिटेक्शन वर्जिन डिटेक्शन और डिफॉल्ट
स्क्रिप्ट स्कैनिंग भी मैं एक साथ ही कर
रहा हूं पोर्ट स्कैनिंग जो डिफॉल्ट
स्क्रिप्ट है ना मैं आपको जो बताया था
कैटेगरी के अकॉर्डिंग उस तरीके से देन
उसके बाद हाइन प सभी पोर्ट के ऊपर हाइन
t44 उसके बाद
192.168 222 यह रहा ट एंटर यह
देखिए प्रो का ब्लॉक कर रहा तो इट्स ओके
हाई
फन पी एन यहा क्योंकि विंडो मशीन है और
फायर वल अगर एक्टिवेट है तो आपके पिम प्रो
को क्या करेगा ब्लॉक करेगा
गुड तो य इस तरीके से काम कर रहा है तो
देखते हैं कितना टाइम व लेगा य 64 पर हो
गया सबको एनएससी समझ में आया एन मैप
स्क्रिप्टिंग इंजन उसको कैसे यूज करना है
और उसकी सारी के सारी जो स्क्रिप्ट है वह
कहां पर अवेलेबल है किस लोकेशन पर अवेलेबल
है कैसे सर्च करना है और पाटिकल जो
स्क्रिप्ट है अगर मुझे उसके बारे में
जानना है कि उसका काम क्या है तो मैं कैसे
पता कर सकता हूं यह सारी चीज समझ में आ गई
सबको क्लियर
है एवरीवन गट क्लियर
कोई ू मिस इस कोर्स को कंप्लीट कीजिए आप
बिगनर नहीं बचोगे इस फील्ड
में इट विल टेक टाइम
भाई हर बार की तरह 49
स्टूडेंट इतने इंपोर्टेंट टॉपिक्स में भी
अगर सीरियस नहीं हो सकते तो कब सीरियस
होगे
यार मेटा स् पलट का इंट्रोडक्शन देखेंगे
हम कि उसके बाद बिगनर लेवल के बाद सॉरी
मैटर इंट्रोडक्शन रहेगा इंट्रोडक्शन के
बाद जो नेक्स्ट क्लास होगी उसमें मेटा
स्लोट में आपको सिखाऊंगा थोड़ा
फंडामेंटल्स आपके क्लियर करूंगा देन उसके
बाद क्या है मेटा स्लोट के नाम से क्लास
नहीं रहेंगी लेकिन उसके बाद जो आपका रहेगा
नमरे सेक्शन में बहुत कुछ सिखाऊंगा आपको
नेट वाय सिखाऊंगा नमरे एसएमबी नमरे आपको
मैं सिखाऊंगा एनएफएस नमरे आपको सिखाऊंगा
वेब सर्वर नमरे माय एसकल एन्यूमरेशन
और
आपके एसन एमपी दे लॉट ऑफ एन्यूमरेशन वी
विल डिस्कस इन वेरी डेप्थ ओके तो नरेशन
कैसे कर सकते हैं हम फर्द किसी भी
सर्विसेस के ऊपर वो मैं आपको सिखाऊंगा विद
द हेल्प ऑफ ऑटोमेशन और विद द हेल्प ऑफ
मैनुअल भी उसके बाद हम फिर एंट्री करेंगे
एक्चुअल जर्नी में जर्नी तो यह भी पार्ट
है सबसे इंपोर्टेंट जो फंडामेंटल पार्ट
आपका यही है अगर अभी आपको चीजें समझ में
नहीं आ रही तो आगे तो शायद आपके लिए थोड़ा
टिपिकल हो जाएंगे फिर
अभी कोर्स तो 1 पर भी डिलीवर नहीं हुआ
मेरे भाई 1 पर नहीं तो 5 पर डिलीवर हो गया
5 टू 10
पर यस मेटा स् पलट के जो पेड वर्जन यूज
होता है
एक्टिव डायरेक्टरी के ऊपर जो पेनिट्रेशन
टेस्टिंग है वह हमारा एडवांस कोर्स है और
डीसी एसपी में करवाया जाता है एक्टिव
डायरेक्टरी पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग फिर भी
अगर आप लोगों को अगर एक्टिव डायरेक्टरी
पेन टेस्टिंग करनी होगी तो ू पर तो नहीं
करवा सकता लेकिन हम आप चाहो तो मैं
वर्कशॉप ले सकता हूं पेड
वर्कशॉप वह हम कर सकते हैं पेड वर्कशॉप
में जैसे कि आप लोग बोलोगे सर हमें थोड़ा
सा प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशन है उन थोड़ा डीप
में जाके थोड़ा मोर फोकस्ड इनप सीखना है
उसके भी वर्कशॉप कर सकते हैं मेटा स्लोट
का एडवांस बस पे भी वर्कशॉप कर सकते हैं
या एक्ट डायरेक्टरी पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग प
भी वर्कशॉप कर सकते हैं ये सारे एज ए
वर्कशॉप पेड वर्कशॉप हम कर सकते हैं बट
उनके लिए तो फिर आप लोग ओनली दो तीन पांच
स्टूडेंट से तो पेड वर्कशॉप नहीं हो सकता
ना एटलीस्ट 100 200 300 तो चाहिए ना एक
वर्कशॉप में फीस आप लोग डिसाइड कर लेना पर
ये 050 में वर्कशॉप नहीं होता क्योंकि
इसके लिए आपके डाउट्स क्लियर करने बहुत
सारी चीजें होती है फिर वर्कशॉप
में अखिलेश राव पाइथन स्क्रिप्टिंग मैं
नहीं बताऊंगा एडवांस को का कोर्स का पार्ट
है जो डीसीएस पी जो पार्ट उसको आपको जवाइन
करना चाहिए
था चलो देखिए यह सारी इंफॉर्मेशन निकली
हमारी देखो यह मैंने क्या
किया कपलीट कर दिया यहां पर भी वही सारी
इंफॉर्मेशन आई जो डिफॉल्ट जो पोर्ट स्कैन
था तो यह सारी इंफॉर्मेशन देखिए बिल्कुल
900 वेब डब्लू एससी फिंगरप्रिंटिंग देखिए
गेट रिक्वेस्ट ओके तो यहां पर कुछ वेब
सर्वर लग रहा है कुछ वेबसाइट एचटीटीपी
माइक्रोसॉफ्ट एचटीटी पी ए ए पीआई एटीटीपी
2.0 दे लॉट ऑफ इंफॉर्मेशन य भी आप देख
सकते हो
देखिए य सारी इंफॉर्मेशन आपकी आ गई इस
कमांड से जो लास्ट में जो कौन सी कमांड थी
ए मैप सील स्कैन हाइन ए का मतलब होता ओस
डिटेक्शन करना सर्विस वर्जन डिटेक्शन करना
साथ में आपको डिफॉल्ट जो स्कैन है उसको भी
यूज करना है देन सभी पोर्ट के ऊपर फास्ट थ
फास्ट फास्ट करना है हाइन पीएन मतलब आपको
क्या करना है ओनली पोर्ट स्कैन करना है
पिंग स्कैन नहीं करना है और दिस इज द
टारगेट आईपी एड्रेस दिस इज द टॉपिक ऑफ योर
एनएससी ओके मैं इसको क्लोज कर रहा हूं
अभी क्लोज
यस ऑथेंटिकेशन ले
लीजिए
ना अभी हम चलते हैं अपने टॉपिक के ऊपर जो
सेक्शन थ्री हमारा उसके ऊपर चलते हैं ओके
सेक्शन थ्री के बाद सबको शायद क्लियर हो
गया होगा एनएससी के बारे में अभी हम बात
करते हैं जो हमारा सेक्शन थी मोस्ट
इंपोर्टेंट
ना आज से हमारा स्टार्ट होने वाला है
सेक्शन थ्र जिसका नाम है एन्यूमरेशन दिस
इज आल्सो मोस्ट इंपोर्टेंट सेक्शन क्योंकि
ये जो सेक्शन है ये डिपेंड करता है आपके
एक्टिव इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग और पैसिव पैसिव
इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग एक्टिव इंफॉर्मेशन
गैदरिंग में पोर्ट स्कैनिंग और जो सारे
काम करते हो तो सर्विस वजन डिटेक्शन करते
हो और जो आप सर्विस वर्जन या जो ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम डिटेक्शन करते हो उसी के बेस पे
आपका क्या है एन्यूमरेशन होता है फर्द कि
उन सर्विसेस पर्टिकुलर सर्विस से रिलेटेड
मैं क्या-क्या इंफॉर्मेशन और जाके निकाल
सकता हूं ओके तो ये आपका एन्यूमरेशन
सेक्शन तो आज हम एन्यूमरेशन सेक्शन की
शुरुआत करते हैं सबसे पहले मैं आपको
बताऊंगा एन्यूमरेशन का इंट्रोडक्शन की
एन्यूमरेशन होता क्या है ओके
नाउ ड्यू टू इंक्रीजिंग ऑफ द डेवलपमेंट ऑफ
नेटवर्क टेक्नोलॉजीज एंड
एप्लीकेशंस नेटवर्क अटैक्स आर आल्सो
इंक्रीजिंग इन बोथ नंबर एंड सीवियरटी
जैसे-जैसे आपके नेटवर्क की जो टेक्नोलॉजी
है जो एप्लीकेशंस है उनकी संख्या बढ़ रही
है वैसे-वैसे नेटवर्क ऊपर जो अटैक्स है वो
भी बढ़ रहे हैं चाहे वो सीवियरिंग की बात
करें चाहे वो संख्या की बात करें दोनों
केसेस में बढ़ रहे हैं एथिकल हैकर्स और
पेन टेस्टर्स आर कंटीन्यूअसली सर्च फॉर
सर्विस एंड
एप्लीकेशंस वल्नरेबल ऑन नेटवर्क एंड
सर्वर्स जो आप जो एथिकल हैकर्स हम लोग हैं
जो पेन टेस्टर्स हम हमारी बात कर रहे हैं
हम कंटीन्यूअसली क्या करते हैं उन
सर्विसेस के ऊपर या जो भी एप्लीकेशंस है
उनके ऊपर क्या करते हैं वन लिमिट फाइंड
आउट करते हैं नेटवर्क और सर्वर्स के सर्वर
के ऊपर ओके व्हेन दे फाइंड ए फ्लो और लूप
होल इन ए सर्विस दैट रन ओवर द इंटरनेट जब
भी उन्हें कोई भी फ्लो या लूप होल मिलता
है उस सर्विस के ऊपर जो आपके इंटरनेट के
ऊपर रन कर रही है दे इमीडिएट ट्राई टू
एक्सप्लोइट इट टू द कंपी टू कम कंप्रोमाइज
द एंटा सिस्टम ओके सॉरी अगेन कि व्हेन दे
फाइंड ए फ्लो और लूप होल इन ए सर्विस दैट
रन ओवर द इंटरनेट दे इमीडिएट
ट्राई टू एक्सप्लोइट इट टू कंप्रोमाइज द
एंटा सिस्टम जैसे ही उन्हें कोई भी फ्लो
या लूप होल किसी भी सर्विस के अंदर मिलता
है तो इमीडिएट वो क्या करते हैं उसको
एक्सप्लोइट करने की कोशिश करते हैं और
एक्सप्लोइट करके पूरे पूरे जो सिस्टम है
उसको कंप्रोमाइज करने की कोशिश करते हैं
एक्सेस गेन एक्सेस मतलब एक्सेस प्राप्त
करने की कोशिश करते हैं एनी अदर डटा दैट
दे फाइंड ड्यूरिंग दिस प्रोसेस मे बी फर्द
यूज टू कंप्रोमाइज एडिशनल नेटवर्क सिस्टम
अभी यह जब सारी प्रोसेस परफॉर्म हो रही
होती है उस टाइम पर अगर कोई भी एडिशनल
डाटा जो इंपोर्टेंट या सेंसिटिव डाटा उनको
मिलता है तो उसको भी यूज करते हैं वे फरदर
जो एडिशनल नेटवर्क डिवाइसेज है है उनको
कंप्रोमाइज करने के लिए अटैकर्स फाइंड आउट
एंड यूज वर्क स्टेशंस विद एडमिनिस्ट्रेटिव
प्रिविलेजेस एंड ट्राई टू रन फ्लड
एप्लीकेशन टू एग्जीक्यूट आर्बिट्रेरी कोड
और इंप्लांट वायरस इन ऑर्डर टू इंटेंस फाइ
डैमेज टू द नेटवर्क जब अटैकर क्या करते
हैं जब यह सारी चीजें एक्सप्ले फाइंड आउट
कर लेते हैं एक बार क्या कर लेते हैं
एक्सेस गेन कर लेते हैं सिस्टम के अंदर
उसके बाद उस वर्क स्टेशन को यूज करते हैं
एडमिनिस्ट्रेटिव प्रिविलेजेस के साथ और
देन उसके ऊपर जो ऑलरेडी पहले से वल्नरेबल
एप्लीकेशंस है या जो बैकडोर्स होंगे वायरस
होंगे माल वेव्स होंगे या कुछ जो डेंजरस
कमांड होंगी उनको रन करते हैं और फर्द
नेटवर्क को डैमेज करने की कोशिश करते हैं
ना
अभी सेक्शन वन में हमने जो बात की थी वह
था आपका पैसिव इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग ओके
सेक्शन टू में जो हमने सीखा था वह आप आपने
सीखा था एक्टिव इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग जहां
पर आपने जो इंफॉर्मेशन कलेक्ट की थी ओपन
पोर्ट्स एंड सर्विसेस ऑपरेशन सिक्योरिटी
डिटेल्स या कोई भी कॉन्फिन लैब्स जो
सेक्शन थ्री है आपका एंड द नेक्स्ट स्टेप
फॉर एन एथिकल हैकर्स और पेन टेस्टर इज टू
प्रोप द टारगेट नेटवर्क फर्द बाय परफॉर्म
एनम मेशन यूजिंग वेरियस टेक्निक यू शुड
एक्स्टेक्स्ट मोर डिटेल्स अबाउट द नेटवर्क
सच एज लिस्ट ऑफ कंप्यूटर्स यूजर नेम यूजर
ग्रुप्स पोर्ट्स
ऑपरेटिंग ऑपरेशन सिक्योरिटी डिटेल्स मशीन
नेम्स नेटवर्क रिसोर्सेस एंड सर्विसेस अभी
क्या करते हो जो थर्ड सेक्शन है उसमें आप
क्या कर सकते हो बहुत सारे टूल्स टेक्निक
का यूज करके यह सारी इंफॉर्मेशन क्या करने
की कोशिश करते हो फाइंड आउट करने की कोशिश
करते हो ड्यूरिंग एनम फेज ओके दिस इज द
थर्ड स्टेप ऑफ योर पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग
जर्नी
नाउ द इंफॉर्मेशन ट यू गेट फ्रॉम द
एन्यूमरेशन स्टप विल हेल्प यू टू
आइडेंटिफिकेशन
होता क्या है एमेशन में हमें मिलता क्या
है तो जो भी इंफॉर्मेशन हमें एमरे स्टेप
में मिल हैं उसका हम यूज करते हैं सिस्टम
के अंदर वलन बिलिटी फाइंड आउट करने के लिए
ओके सिस्टम के अंदर वलन बिलिटी फाइंड आउट
करने के लिए ओके सच इंफॉर्मेशन कुड आल्सो
इनेबल अटैकर टू परफॉर्म पासवर्ड अटैक्स टू
गेन अन ऑथराइज एक्सेस टू इंफॉर्मेशन
सिस्टम रिसोर्सेस ओके अभी जो इंफॉर्मेशन
हमें मिलती है इसके अंदर एमेशन स्टेप के
अंदर उस इंफॉर्मेशन का यूज करके हम क्या
करते हैं पासवर्ड अटैक या ब्रूट फोर्स
अटैक बोल सकते हैं या डिक्शनरी अटैक जिनको
हम बोल सकते हैं वो ट्राई करते हैं और
अनऑथराइज्ड वे से हम क्या करते हैं सिस्टम
के अंदर एंट्री करने की कोशिश करते हैं या
उसके बारे में कुछ सेंसिटिव इंफॉर्मेशन
गैदरिंग करने की कोशिश करते हैं ओके
ड्यूरिंग
एन्यूमरेशन इन द प्रीवियस स्टेप्स ऑफ द
पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग यू गैदर्ड नेसेसरी
इंफॉर्मेशन अबाउट अ टारगेट
विदाउट कंट्रावेने एनी लीगल बाउंड्रीज फिर
भी मैंने आपको बताया था जब एक्टिवली आप
इंगेज करते हो तो आपको परमिशन चाहिए फिर
फिर भी अभी तक आपने क्या किया है कि अभी
भी कोई भी लीगल या इलीगल चीजें नहीं की है
लेकिन जब हम बात करते हैं आपके नरेशन
एक्टिविटीज की यह डिपेंड करती है आपकी
ऑर्गेनाइजेशन पॉलिसी के ऊपर या जिस शहर
में या जिस देश में आप रह रहे हो वहां की
पॉलिसी के ऊपर उसके लॉ के ऊपर की आप वहां
पर यह सारी चीजें कर सकते हो या नहीं कर
सकते तो मेरे कहने का मतलब सीधा सा यह है
सो एज एन एथिकल हैकर और पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टर
यू शड ऑलवेज एक्वायर प्रॉपर ऑथराइजेशन
बिफोर परफॉर्मिंग एन्यूमरेशन तो मैं आपसे
हमेशा यही बोलूंगा कि पैसिव इंफॉर्मेशन
गैदरिंग के बाद जो भी आप स्टेप परफॉर्म
करोगे उन सबके लिए आपके पास एक प्रॉपर
ऑथराइजेशन होना चाहिए ऑर्गेनाइजेशन की तरफ
से अदर वाइज मत कीजिए वरना आप खुद को बहुत
बड़ी समस्या में फंसा लोगे या कहीं पर खुद
से फंस जाओगे और आपको पता है साइबर लॉ
बहुत ही टाइट्स है एक बार उनके चक्कर में
फंसे तो शायद आपने कुछ किया भी नहीं होगा
लेकिन आप फस जाओगे ओके तो प्लीज प्रॉपर
ऑथराइजेशन लीजिए आप किसी के ऊपर अगर टेस्ट
करना चाहते हो रियल इंडस्ट्री के ऊपर उस
ऑर्गेनाइजेशन का प्रॉपर ऑथराइजेशन लेने
में कोई शरमा नहीं है कोई भी तकलीफ नहीं
करनी चाहिए क्योंकि आप अपने आप को बचा रहे
हो रैंडम नहीं कि किसी ने आया बोला यार
मेरी वेबसाइट है यार इसपे काम कर तुमने तो
कोर्स किया हुआ है यू आर एथिकल हैकर तुम
अपने आप को बोलते हो तो यार एक बार टेस्ट
करना कि क्या प्रॉब्लम है प्लीज मत कीजिए
उससे बोलिए कि मुझे एक रिटर्न अथॉरिटी के
ू क्या एक रिटर्न वो चाहिए अथॉरिटी चाहिए
मुझे लिखित में चाहिए तभी मैं इस पर
करूंगा क्योंकि वोह तो आपको ऐसे ही बोले
हो सकता है उसकी वेबसाइट है या नहीं है
बाद में उसके साथ कुछ उसके डाटा डिलीट हो
गया या कुछ इंफॉर्मेशन लीक होगी तो क्या
हो डायरेक्टली आप ब्लेम कर देगा क्योंकि
वहां पर आपके लोग भी मिलेंगे सर्वर के
अंदर क्योंकि इतने तो माहिर हो ग नहीं आप
तो अब उससे क्या कि लास्ट में आप ही को
समस्या देखने को मिलेगी खुद के साथ
नाउ जो ऑब्जेक्टिव है एन्यूमरेशन का यहां
पर आपको पता चल गया मशीन का नेम देयर
ऑपरेशन सिक्योरिटी डिटेल्स सर्विसेस एंड
पोर्ट्स नेटवर्क रिसोर्सेस यूजर नेम यूजर
ग्रुप्स लिस्ट ऑफ शेयर्स ऑन होस्ट पॉलिसीज
एंड पासवर्ड पॉलिसीज राउटिंग टेबल
इंफॉर्मेशन और भी ज्यादा इंफॉर्मेशन हो
सकती है जो हमें मिलती है अगर आपकी जो
सर्विसेस है मिस
कॉन्फिडो यह था एक छोटा सा सेक्शन आपका
इंट्रोडक्शन टू एन्यूमरेशन अभी फर्द
एन्यूमरेशन में हम तभी बढ़ेंगे उससे पहले
हम एक इंपॉर्टेंट जो फ्रेमवर्क है कौन सा
मेटा स्प्ड फ्रेमवर्क है उसके बारे में
डिस्कस करेंगे उसके बारे में सीखेंगे वह
क्या होता है कैसे काम करता है और उसको
कैसे यूज करते हैं देन उसके बाद फर्द जो
एन्यूमरेशन स्टेप्स है कि नमरे कैसे करते
हैं किसी भी सर्विसेस के ऊपर या किसी भी
पोर्ट के ऊपर तो वो कैसे करते हैं वो सारी
चीजें हम बाद में सीखेंगे उससे पहले जो एक
इंपोर्टेंट फ्रेमवर्क है सबका फेवरेट
फ्रेमवर्क है उसके बारे में हम डिस्कस
करेंगे उसके बारे में सीखेंगे देन हम फर्द
फिर कंटिन्यू करेंगे हमारे एन्यूमरेशन
सेक्शन में या न्यूमरेशन स्टेप के ऊपर तो
स्टिल आपको पता चल गया कि नरेशन क्या होता
है
एवरीवन यह सारे के सारे
देखो यह जो मैं आपके सामने हाईलाइट कर रहा
हूं यह एक जनरल इंफॉर्मेशन है बेसिकली
क्या है कि हम यह सारी चीज डीप में जाक
इंफॉर्मेशन करेंगे ये एक्टिव इंफॉर्मेशन
गैदरिंग में भी ये सारी इंफॉर्मेशन आपको
मिल जाती है लेकिन जैसे कि यूजर्स नेम या
यूजर ग्रुप्स शेयर्स की लिस्ट या पासवर्ड
पॉलिसीज या सर्विसेस के अंदर और जाके
सर्विसेस के थ्रू सिस्टम की इंफॉर्मेशन ये
थोड़ी एन्यूमरेशन फेज में मिलती है
ज्यादातर एक्टिव इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग में
नहीं मिलते एन्यूमरेशन में क्या करते हो
टोटली उसी सर्विस पे उसी सर्विस के
रिगार्डिंग टूल यूज करते हो आप या उसी
सर्विस के रिगार्डिंग स्क्रिप्ट यूज करते
हो या उसी सर्विस के रिगार्डिंग आप खुद के
स्क्रिप्ट राइट डाउन करते हो उस सर्विस को
समझ के और फर्द उसको क्या करोगे ऐसी
इंफॉर्मेशन फाइंड आउट करगे सो दैट कि उसके
ऊपर आपको वलन बिटी मिल मिल पाए ओके देन
उसके बाद ही वलम स्कैनिंग होगी एन्यूमरेशन
करोगे तभी आप वोलमेट स्कैनिंग कर पाओ
क्योंकि आपके पास ही तभी आपके पास जाके
क्या होगी सॉलिड इंफॉर्मेशन होगी और जरूरी
नहीं कि एन्यूमरेशन ओनली यहीं पर की जाती
है जब एक बार आप क्या कर लेते हो सिस्टम
को टेकओवर कर लेते हो एक्सेस कर लेते हो
तो उसके बाद भी क्या है कि हो सकता है कि
वो किसी और नेटवर्क से जुड़ा हो वो सिस्टम
तो उस केस में भी आप क्या करते हो
एन्यूमरेशन करते हो फिर से कि दूसरे
सिस्टम के बारे में इंफॉर्मेशन निकाल के
फर्द उनको एक्सप्लोइट करने के लिए तो
एन्यूमरेशन में बहुत कुछ होता है ओनली यही
कि अभी अभी हम एन्यूमरेशन करते हैं नहीं
एक बार सिस्टम को हम एक्सेस गेन कर लेते
हैं तब भी हम उसके बाद भी फिर एन्यूमरेशन
करते हैं तो एमेशन रिलेटेड कोई भी डाउट है
किसी का प्लीज नेक्स्ट वन मिनट में पूछ
लीजिए अभी मैं चैट सेक्शन देख रहा हूं
ओनली रिलेटेड टू टॉपिक डाउट पूछना अभी
फालतू का कोई सवाल मत पूछना उसके बाद हम
मेटा स्ट फ्रेमवर्क पर चलेंगे
देर ओनली 38 स्टूडेंट्स
तो मेरे लिए काफी शर्म की बात है अभी मैं
सेशन स्ट्रीम को एंड कर दूंगा
अभी 38 में मैं नहीं पढ़ा पाऊंगा
तभी तो बोल रहा हूं कि अखिलेश आपको एक्टिव
इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग आपको परमिशन के साथ ही
करना
है ब्लैक हैट वे में करना चाहते हो
क्या उसके लिए तो आपको फिर सिक्योर
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम जैसे टेल ओस क्यूब ओस और
बहुत सारी चीजें हैं जो आपको करनी पड़ेगी
फिर वो एक अलग क्या बोलते हैं कि अलग
दुनिया है कि हाउ टू स्टे एनोनिमस एक चीज
सुनी है उसके ऊपर जैसे बुक है उसके उसके
ऊपर बहुत सारी ट्रिक्स और टेक्निक्स होती
है कि आप अपने आप को एनोनिमस कैसे रख सकते
हो उसका अपना एक सेपरेट एक आप बोलो तो
बोलते है ना कि उसको अगर आप कोर्स डिलीवर
करोगे तो घंटों में कई घंटों में जाके
कोर्स वो जाके डिलीवर होगा क्योंकि एक
अपने आप में बहुत ही इंटरेस्टिंग टॉपिक है
वो बहुत इंटरेस्टिंग चीज है उसको सीखने
में और उसको अप्लाई करने में क्योंकि वो
फिर अलग दुनिया होती है थोड़ी सी
हा अगर एनिमेशन स्टेप में आपको डाटा मिलता
तो आपके पास आ
जाएगा तो उमेश मोबाइल जब हैक कर लोगे तो
एन्यूमरेशन थोड़ी ना वो वो तो आप
एन्यूमरेशन से बहुत आगे बढ़ गए डाटा तो आ
जाएगा आपके
पास अभी देखो मोबाइल की हम आपको समझा तो
मोबाइल की सिक्योरिटी अलग होती है उसका
काम करने का तरीका अलग होता है अगर वह
जानना है आपको कैसे काम करता है तो हमारे
डेफ सर्टिफाइड एंड्राइड पेन टेस्टिंग को
जवाइन कीजिए जो एक पेड कोर्स है उसमें
सिखाया जाता है य कि जो एड एप्लीकेशन है
उसमें वनटी कैसे फाइंड आउट की जाती है
कैसे रिवर्स इंजीनियरिंग की जाती है और
कैसे उसको समझा जाता है तो व एक सेपरेट
टॉपिक
है कोई डाउट है किसी का प्लीज पूछ लीजिए
नहीं इतना नहीं देखो ब्लू टीम सामने बैठे
हुए हैं नेटवर्क ट्रैफिक को वो भी एनालाइज
करते हैं लेकिन जब मैंने आपको बताया ना जो
कुछ टिक्स ट्रिक्स
वो तो एनालाइज कर ही लेंगे यार कुछ चीजों
में लेकिन अगर आपका ट्रैफिक अलग तरीके से
आ रहा है अगर आपने कमांड एंड कंट्रोल यूज
किया है और थोड़े से ट्रिक्स है कि मैं
आपको क्या बताऊं कि आपने जो उसका पोर्ट
चाहता है उस टाइप की इंफॉर्मेशन जो उसकी
फायर वाल चाहती है उस टाइप की इंफॉर्मेशन
जाएगी उसी के थ्रू आप क्या कर पाओ
इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग कर पाओ
तो नॉट इजी टू डिटेक्ट ओके बाकी ब्लू
ट्यूमर का भी काम है तो गलतिया उनसे भी
होती है
यस उमेश वो भी मैं ही पढ़ाता
हूं चलो फिर हम स्टार्ट करते हैं मेटा
स्प्ड फ्रेमवर्क के बारे में
इंट्रोडक्शन टू मेटा स्प्ड फ्रेमवर्क द
मेटा स्लोट फ्रेमवर्क इज एन ओपन सोर्स
पावरफुल पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग एंड
एक्सप्लोइटेशन फ्रेमवर्क दैट इज यूज्ड बाय
पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टर्स एंड सिक्योरिटी
प्रोफेशनल वर्ल्ड वाइड यह एक ओपन सोर्स
फ्रेमवर्क है
ओके दिस फ्रेमवर्क कैन डू लॉट ऑफ योर
टास्क ऑटोमेटिक मींस इट कैन ऑटोमेट
ऑलमोस्ट एवरी स्टेज ऑफ द पेनिट्रेशन
टेस्टिंग लाइफ साइकिल अब इसका मतलब क्या
है फॉर एग्जांपल इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग
एक्सप्लोइटेशन पोस्ट एक्सप्लोइटेशन प्लीज
एस्केलेशन एटस इट कैन डू ऑल द टास्क
ऑटोमेटिक देखो पहली बात तो जो आपका मेटा
स्प्ड फ्रेमवर्क है एक ओपन सोर्स
फ्रेमवर्क है बेसिकली क्या है फ्री है ओपन
सोर्स अवेलेबल है जिसको क्या सभी
पेंटेस्टर्स है या जो सिक्योरिटी
प्रोफेशनल है वर्ल्ड वाइड सभी यूज करते ही
करते हैं दूसरा दरा क्या है कि आपके जो
पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग के अंदर जितने भी
फेजस होते हैं आपका इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग से
लेकर आपके पोस्ट एक्सप्लोइटेशन तक प्रिज
एस्केलेशन तक या रिवर्स सेल लेने तक उन
सारे के सारे टास्क को क्या कर सकता है
ऑटोमेटिक कर सकता है आप अभी तक मैनुअली कर
रहे थे लेकिन यह ऑटोमेटिक उन सारे टास्क
को कर सकता है ठीक है दूसरा इट कैन आल्सो
बी यूज्ड बाय एक्सप्लोइट डेवलपर्स टू
डेवलप एंड टेस्ट देर न्यू एक्सप्लोइट अभी
जो मेटा स्लोट फ्रेमवर्क है यह जो
एक्सप्लोइट डेवलपर्स होते हैं जो
एक्सप्लोइट को डेवलप करते हैं हमारे वो वो
भी मेटा स्प्ड फ्रेमवर्क को यूज करते हैं
क्यों क क्योंकि उन्होने जो एक्सप्लो
बनाया है उसको टेस्ट करने के लिए कि यह
मेटा जो स्प्लिट जो फ्रेमवर्क है वो उसको
डिटेक्ट कर पा रहा है या नहीं कर पा रहा
ओके क्योंकि द मेटा स्प्लिट फ्रेमवर्क हैज
वन ऑफ द वर्ल्ड लार्जेस्ट डेटाबेस ऑफ द
पब्लिक टेस्टेड एक्सट क्योंकि मेटा स्पोट
के पास वर्ल्ड का सबसे लार्जेस्ट डेटाबेस
अवेलेबल है एक्सप्लोइट्स का इसलिए
एक्सप्लोइट जो डेवलपर्स है अपने
एक्सप्लोइट को टेस्टिंग करने के लिए भी
मेटा स्पेड फ्रेमवर्क का यूज करते हैं नाउ
वन क्वेश्चन कम्स इन योर माइंड व्हाई वुड
आई वांट टू ऑटोमेट समथिंग और व्हाई वुड आई
वांट टू ऑटोमेट ए पेनिट्रेशन
टेस्ट मुझे ऑटोमेट ऑटोमेशन की जरूरत ही
क्या है यह आप लोगों का सवाल हो सकता है
तो इसका जवाब सुनिए इफ यू डूइंग इट
मैनुअली इट विल इवॉल्व लॉट ऑफ स्टेप्स फॉर
एग्जांपल डाउनलोडिंग द एक्सप्लोइट कोड
मॉडिफाइड कंपाइलिंग द एक्सप्लोइट मे बी इट
ट्रांसफरिंग टू टारगेट सिस्टम तो ऑल ऑफ
दीज थिंग्स टेक्स टाइम अब जब हम बात करते
हैं कि जब मैनुअली सारी चीजें करते हैं कि
जब मुझे मुझे क्या करती है सिस्टम के अंदर
वटी मिल गई तो मैं क्या करूंगा उसके
अगेंस्ट एक एक्सप्लोइट फाइंड आउट करूंगा
एक्सप्लोइट फाइंड आउट करने के बाद उसको
मैं डाउनलोड करूंगा डाउनलोड करके उस
एक्सप्लोइट को मडि
करूंगा क्योंकि मुझे समझ में आए ना आए देन
उसको फर कंपाइल करूंगा कंपाइल करने के बाद
ही मैं उसको यूज करूंगा अभी यूज करने से
पहले हो सकता है कि जो मेरा टारगेट सिस्टम
है उसके ऊपर मुझे ट्रांसफर भी करना पड़े
मतलब लेटरल मूवमेंट या पाइ वेटिंग वो भी
करना पड़े तो ये सारी की सारी चीजें क्या
होंगी टाइम लेंगी तो इस केस में आपका जो
मेटा स्पेट फ्रेमवर्क है वह प्ले करता है
प्ले में आता है मतलब रोल में आता है वेर
यू कैन इजली टेस्ट योर टारगेट वेदर इट्स
लबल और नॉट टू ए पर्टिकुलर एक्सप्लो विद
इन ए फ्यू सेकंड कुछ ही सेकंड में आप यह
पता कर लोगे कि जो मेरा टारगेट है वो
वल्नरेबल है या नहीं है ओके जीरो डे की
बात नहीं करी बिल्कुल ही नई वनबिल है तो
उसका तो आईडिया मेटा स्लोट को भी नहीं है
लेकिन जो डेटाबेस आउट जहां से आप
एक्सप्लोइट फाइंड आउट करोगे जिस भी
डेटाबेस से वो सारे एक्सप्लोइट क्या है
आपके मैट स्प्ड के डेटाबेस में भी अवेलेबल
है उसके ऊपर भी मॉड्यूस अवेलेबल है
नाउ द मेटा स्लट फ्रेमवर्क इज डिजाइन टू
बी मॉड्यूलर इज डिजाइन टू बी मॉड्यूलर
इसका मतलब क्या होता है कि मॉड्यूलर क्या
होता है किसी को पता है मॉड्यूलर क्या
होता
है किसी को पता है मॉड्यूलर टर्म का मतलब
क्या है यहां पर जिसने पढ़ा है वह बता
दीजिए
नहीं ये एक ट्रम है आपको समझाने के लिए कि
मेटा स्लट के बारे
में इसका मतलब यह है कि अगर आप मेटा स्लट
फ्रेमवर्क के अंदर
कोई फंक्शन टी ऐड करना चाहते हो खुद से तो
वह भी कर सकते हो किसकी फॉर्म में मॉड्यूल
की फॉर्म में क्योंकि मेटा स्प्लिट
फ्रेमवर्क के अंदर जितनी भी फंक्शन टी यूज
की जाती है वह सारी के सारी मॉड्यूल की
फॉर्म में डील की जाती है या उनको क्या
किया जाता है मॉड्यूस की फॉर्म में हैंडल
किया जाता है अगर आपको मॉड्यूस क्रिएट
करने आते हैं तो आप खुद का मॉड्यूल क्रिएट
करके मेटा स् पलट फॉम फ्रेम के अंदर क्या
कर सकते हो आप फ्रेमवर्क के अंदर
इंटीग्रेट करके उसको को यूज कर सकते हो
इसलिए मे इसलिए इसका मतलब है मॉड्यूलर
मतलब द मेटा स्पेट फ्रेमवर्क इ डिजाइन टू
बी मॉड्यूलर आप उसमें क्या कर सकते हो खुद
से खुद के मॉड्यूल भी इंटीग्रेट करके मेटा
स्लेट को यूज कर सकते हो अगर आप खुद आपको
खुद से क्रिएट करना आता है तो अभी बात
करते हैं हम हिस्ट्री ऑफ द मेटा स्पेड
फ्रेमवर्क इट वास डेवलप्ड बाय एच डी मोरे
इन
2003 एंड ओरिजनली डेवलप्ड इन पर्ल
लैंग्वेज 2003 में इसको डी मोरे साहब के
द्वारा डेवलप किया गया और इसको ओरिजनली
परल लैंग्वेज में लिखा गया था बाद में
2007 में इसको फिर से लिखा गया रिराइज में
रूबी लैंग्वेज में अब 2009 में रैपिड से
ने इसको एक्वायर कर लिया और 2019 में मेटा
स्ट वर्जन 5.0 रिलीज हुआ इसका और 2020 में
इसका मेटा स्लट वर्जन 6.0 रिलीज हुआ जो
अभी 6.0 वर्जन ही जिसके साथ आप काम करोगे
तो यह थोड़ी सी हिस्ट्री थी आपकी मेटा
स्पेड फ्रेमवर्क की जो थोड़ा सा आपको पता
होना चाहिए इसकी भी हिस्ट्री क्योंकि एक
मोस्ट पॉपुलर फ्रेमवर्क है तो उसकी
हिस्ट्री तो पता होनी चाहिए
नाउ अभी मेटा स्प्लिट फ्रेमवर्क के कुछ
वर्जन एडिशन अवेलेबल है तो मार्केट में
इसके तीन ही एडिशन अवेलेबल है मेटा स्लेट
प्रो मेटा स्लेट एक्सप्रेस मेटा स्प्लिट
फ्रेमवर्क जो मेटा स्प्लिट प्रो है और
मेटा स्प्लिट एक्सप्रेस है यह कमर्शियल
परपज के लिए है कमर्शियल यूज के लिए है यह
पेड पेड वर्जंस है यहां पर आपको लाइसेंस
चाहिए इनको यूज करने के लिए जो मेड स्प्ड
फ्रेमवर्क का यह ओपन सोर्स है और फ्री टू
यूज ऑल है ठीक है और इसी को हम यूज करने
वाले अपने पूरी पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग जर्नी
के दौरान मेटा स्लेड फ्रेमवर्क जिसको हम
एमएसएफ कंसोल बोलते हैं जो एक फ्री और ओपन
सोर्स है यह जो ऊपर वाले हैं यह दोनों के
दोनों क्या है पेड है इनके लिए आपको
लाइसेंस
चाहिए अभी बात करते हैं न टॉक अबाउट मेटा
स्लेड फ्रेमवर्क देयर इज अ फ्यू पीसेज ऑफ
टर्मिनोलॉजी दैट यू नीड टू बी अवेयर ऑफ इट
जब हम मेटा स्लेट फ्रेमवर्क की बात करते
हैं तो हमारे पास कुछ टर्मिनोलॉजी है
जिनके बारे में हमें पता होना चाहिए
क्योंकि जब भी हम मेटा स्ड यूज करेंगे तो
इन टर्मिनोलॉजी का हम यूज करते ही करते
हैं और इनके बारे में पता इसलिए होना
चाहिए ताकि जब मैं इस टर्मिनल को यूज करूं
तो आपको समझ में आना चाहिए ओके इसका मतलब
यह हो सकता है क्योंकि हमने पढ़ा था तो
सबसे पहली जो टर्मिनोलॉजी है वो है
इंटरफेस मेथड्स ऑफ इंटरेक्ट ंग विद द मेटा
स्लेड फ्रेमवर्क अगर मैं कहीं पर बोलता
हूं कि इंटरफेस तो इसका मतलब क्या है कि
मैं मेट फ्लोट से जो फ्रेमवर्क उसे
इंटरेक्ट करने का कौन सा तरीका यूज कर रहा
हूं तो उसको बोलते हैं इंटरफेस जैसे कि
मेटा स्ड कंसोल या मेटा स्ड कमांड लाइन
कके मैंने एमएसएफ कंसोल इंटरफेस को यूज कर
इसका मतलब क्या है कि मेटा स्ड फ्रेमवर्क
से करने के लिए इंटरेक्ट करने के लिए
मैंने यूज किया है
इसको मेटा स्प्ड कंसोल को जो सेकंड है
मॉड्यूल इट इ ऑफ कोड दैट परफॉर्म ए
पर्टिकुलर टास्क एन एग्जांपल ऑफ ए मॉड्यूल
इज एन एक्सलेट बेसिकली मॉड्यूल क्या है
मॉड्यूल एक पीस ऑफ कोड है जो किसी एक
पर्टिकुलर टास्क को परफॉर्म करने के लिए
बनाया गया है तो जब भी हम मॉड्यूल की बात
करेंगे इसका मतलब क्या है एक पीस ऑफ कोड
है वल्नरेबल की बात करें तो वीकनेसेस और
फ्लो इन ए कंप्यूटर सिस्टम नेटवर्क दैट
कैन बी एक्सप्लोइटेड ओके वनबिल की जब भी
मैं बोलता हूं कि वनबिल इसका मतलब क्या है
कि एक कंप्यूटर सिस्टम या नेटवर्क के अंदर
कोई भी फ्लो या वीकनेस का मतलब है मेरा आज
जब मैं यूज करता हूं एक्सप्लोइट वर्ड को
तो इसका मतलब क्या ए मॉड्यूल मॉड्यूल क्या
है एक पीस ऑफ कोड दैट इज यूज टू टेक
एडवांटेज ऑफ वल्नरेबल टेक एडवांटेज ऑफ
वल्नरेबल विद इन ए सिस्टम सर्विस और
एप्लीकेशन ओके जब मैं एक्सप्लोइट का वड
वर्ड का यूज़ करता हूं इसका मतलब क्या है
कि एक मॉड्यूल है जिसका हम यूज करते हैं
सिस्टम के अंदर या सर्विस के अंदर या
एप्लीकेशन के अंदर जो वलन बिलिटी अवेलेबल
है उसकी एडवांटेज लेने के लिए अगर मैं यूज
करता हूं पेलोड शब्द को या वर्ड को इसका
मतलब क्या है पीस ऑफ कोड डिलीवर्ड टू द
टारगेट सिस्टम बाय एन एक्सप्लोइट मॉड्यूल
एक्सप्लोइट मॉड्यूल के द्वारा एक पीस ऑफ
कोड क्या किया जाता है डिलीवर किया जाता
है ओके सो एन एक्सप्लोर टेक्स एन एडवांटेज
ऑफ ए वल्नरेबल एंड देन पेलोड इज व्हाट दैट
इज ड्रॉप्ड ऑन टू द टारगेट एक्सप्लोइट
वनटी के एडवांटेज लेता है फायदा उठाता है
और पेलोड क्या है जो टारगेट के ऊपर ड्रॉप
किया जाता है द ऑब्जेक्टिव ऑफ पेलोड इज
आइर टू एग्जीक्यूट आर्बिट्रेरी कमांड्स और
रिमोट एक्सेस टू एन अटैकर अगर इसके
ऑब्जेक्टिव की बात करें तो इसका
ऑब्जेक्टिव सिंपल सा य है तो ये आपको क्या
है कि जो कमांड्स रन करने की सुविधा देता
है य आपको रिमोट एक्सेस दे देता है द
क्लाइंट के सिस्टम के ऊपर या टारगेट के
सिस्टम के ऊपर अगर हम बात करते हैं लिनर
की यूटिलिटी दैट लिसेंस फॉर एन इनकमिंग
कनेक्शन फ्रॉम ए टारगेट अब मैं बोलता हूं
कि ओके मुझे लिनर ऑन किया है मेटा स्प्ड
में मतलब क्या है कि मैंने कनेक्शन ओपन कर
दिया सो दैट कि जब मैं रिवर्स सेल खासकर
रिवर्स सेल के केस में हम इसको यूज करते
हैं कि मैंने व मैट मिटर प्रेटर लिनर या
मैंने एक लिस्नर ऑन किया है लिस्नर का
मतलब क्या है कि मैं एक पर्टिकुलर पोर्ट
के ऊपर क्या कर रहा हूं वेट कर रहा हूं
कनेक्शन के एस्टेब्लिश होने का ये एक
लिस्नर है तो बेसिकली जब भी आपको इंटरफेस
वर्ड सुनने को मिले मॉड्यूल वर्ड वलने
बिलिटी एक्सप्लोइट पेलोड लिनर तो साद आपको
दिमाग माक में आ जाना चाहिए ओके सर का
मतलब यह है ओके मेटा स्लोट के केस में
एवरीवन गट क्लियर टिल
नाउ साइबर एआई मेटा स्टेबल क्या है
वल्नरेबल मशीनस है
नाउ फॉर एग्जांपल इन टर्मिनोलॉजी को जो
मैंने ज आपको बताया तो उसको मैं कैसे यूज
करूंगा और कैसे आप यूज करते देखो फॉर
एग्जांपल लेट्स से वी हैव एन एक्सप्लोइट
एंड दिस पर्टिकुलर एक्सप्लोइट टेक द
एडवांटेज ऑफ ए बफर ओवरफ्लो वलने बिलिटी ऑन
द टारगेट सिस्टम एंड द एक्सप्लोइट इज
आल्सो कपल्ड विद ए पेलोड एंड द पेलोड विल
अगेन प्रोवाइड अस विद ए रिवर्स सेल ऑन द
टारगेट सिस्टम ये मेरा टारगेट सिस्टम है
इसके ऊपर एक वनटी है बफर ओवरफ्लो और मेरे
पास क्या है एक एक्सप्लोइट है और
एक्सप्लोइट मेरा किसके साथ कपल कर रखा है
एक साथ जुड़े हुए हैं आपस में पेलोड के
साथ तो जैसे ही मैं क्या करूंगा यहां पर
एक्सप्लोइट पे क्लिक करूंगा लॉन्च करूं तो
एक्सप्लोइट क्या करेगा आपके टारगेट सिस्टम
पर जो अवेलेबल वनटी है बफर ओवरफ्लो उसका
फायदा उठाएगा और यहां पर पेलोड को ड्रॉप
कर देगा और आपका पेलोड यहां पर क्या करेगा
एग्जीक्यूट होगा और एग्जीक्यूट करने के
बाद यहां पर क्या एक पोर्ट लिसन कर रहा
होगा लिसन कर रहे हम किसी पो पोट प तो उस
स्पोट प क्या करेगा एक कनेक्शन एस्टेब्लिश
कर देगा एक रिवर्स कनेक्शन एस्टेब्लिश कर
देगा आपका टारगेट के साथ और इस कनेक्शन प
आप क्या कर सकते हो फर्द अपनी कमांड रन कर
सकते हो फर्द उसके बारे में इंफॉर्मेशन
गैदर कर सकते हो फदर या एक्सप्लोइटेशन
परफॉर्म कर सकते हो फदर उसके ऊपर एमरे
प्रिज एस्केलेशन वो सारे काम कर सकते हो
तो यह है वो टर्मिनोलॉजी जो हम यूज करते
हैं
नाउ अभी मेटा स्ट इंटरफेस की बात करते हैं
कि देर वेरियस इंटरफेस आर अवेलेबल दैट
अलाउ यू टू इंटरेक्ट विद द मेटा स्लेड
फ्रेमवर्क अगर मुझे मेटा स्लेड फ्रेमवर्क
के साथ इंटरेक्ट करना है तो उसके लिए दे
आर लॉट दे आर सम फ्यू इंटरफेस आर अवेलेबल
नाउ दज आर द लिस्ट ऑफ इंटरफेस सबसे पहले
हमारा कौन सा है मेटा स्प्ड फ्रेमवर्क
कंसोल जिसको हम बोलते हैं एमएसएफ कंसोल इस
तरीके दिखता है जिसको हम यूज करने वाले
हैं और ज्यादातर यूज भी किया जाता है
एमएसएफ कंसोल इज एन इजी टू यूज ऑल इन वन
इंटरफेस दैट प्रोवाइड यू विद एक्सेस टू ऑल
द फंक्शन टी ऑफ द मेटा स्प्लिट फ्रेमवर्क
ऑल द फंक्शन ऑफ मेटा स्प्लिट फ्रेमवर्क
मतलब ऑल इन वन इंटरफेस है सारी की सारी
फंक्शनल क्या है एमएसएफ कंसल के के अंदर
अवेलेबल होती है नाउ सेकंड जो इंटरफेस है
मेटा स्प्लिट फ्रेमवर्क फ्रेमवर्क सीएल आई
जो सेकंड इंटरफेस था अब नहीं है द मेटा
स्प्ड फ्रेमवर्क कमांड लाइन इंटरफेस इज ए
कमांड लाइन यूटिलिटी दैट इज यूज टू
फैसिलिटेट द क्रिएशन ऑफ ऑटोमेशन स्क्रिप्ट
दैट यूटिलाइज मेटा स्प्लिट मॉड्यूल बट इन
2015 इट वाज डिस कंटिन्यू एंड सेम फंक्शन
कैन बी अचीव्ड थ्रू द एमएसएफ कंसोल अब
इसको डिस्कंटीन्यू कर दिया गया है इसको
यूज नहीं किया जाता 2015 के बाद और इसकी
जो सारी की सारी फंक्शनल है आपके एमएसएफ
कंसोल के अंदर देखने को मिलती है तो इसके
इसलिए इसके बारे में फर्द जानने की जरूरत
नहीं है यह आपका मेटा स्प्लिट कम्युनिटी
एडिशन मतलब क्या है इट इज अ वेब बेस्ड
ग्राफिकल यूजर इंटरफेस फ्रंट एंड ऑफ द
मेटा स्प्ड फ्रेमवर्क ये इस तरीके दिखता
है मतलब आप सील आई यूज करें तो यह
ग्राफिकल है काम सेम करता है सेम फंटी है
लेकिन यहां पर जो आपको आउटपुट दि है वो
ग्राफिकल वे में देखने को मिलेगा जो फोर्थ
आपका आर्मी टेक आर्मी टेक इज ए फ्री जावा
बेस्ड ग्राफिकल यूजर इंटरफेस फ्रंट एंड
फॉर द मेटा स्प्ड फ्रेमवर्क दैट सिंपलीफाई
नेटवर्क डिस्कवरी एक्सप्लोइटेशन पोस्ट
एक्सप्लोइटेशन सो लिटरली एनीथिंग दैट यू
कैन डू विद इन द मेटा स्लेट कंसोल यू कैन
डू विद द आर्मी टेक बेसिकली ये भी क्या है
एक जावा में डेवलप किया हुआ ग्राफिकल यूजर
इंटरफेस है जो क्या करता है आपके मेटा
स्लिट फ्रेमवर्क के साथ क्या करता है
इंटरेक्ट करता है इस तरीके से आपको रिजल्ट
शो करता है आपके स्क्रीन के ऊपर कभी किसी
ने यूज किया हो तो तो ये भी क्या है आपका
मेटा स्कट फ्रेमवर्क के से ही इंटरेक्ट
करता है ओके तो जो जो काम आप एमएसएफ कंसोल
के अंदर कर सकते हो वो सारे काम इसके अंदर
भी कर सकते हो तो दीज आर द सम इंटरफेस दैट
आर अवेलेबल टू इंटरेक्ट विद द मेटा
स्प्लिट फ्रेमवर्क एवरीवन गट क्लियर टिल
नाउ
बताइए
नेक्स्ट तो अभी आज क्लास को हम इधर ही एंड
करते हैं और एमएसएफ मॉड्यूल से क्लास
स्टार्ट करेंगे नेक्स्ट क्लास ओके मेटा
स्ड फ्रेमवर्क मॉड्यूस क्या होते हैं उसके
बाद हम बात करेंगे पेलो टाइप्स के उसके
बाद करेंगे इनम डिफरेंस क्या होता है फिर
कुछ और फेमस चीज जिनके बारे में हम बात
करें क्योंकि काफी टाइम हो गया है क्लास
को यहीं पर फिनिश करते हैं ओके क्योंकि आज
स्टार्टिंग में कुछ 10 टू 15 मिनट जो थी
वो थोड़ी सी प्रॉब्लमैटिक हो गई थी थोड़ा
सा कुछ सवाल जवाब हो गए थे और स्टार्टिंग
में मुझे शायद मुझे लगता है कि थोड़ा
कंफ्यूजन हो गया है कुछ चीजों को लेकर और
मैंने कुछ गलत इंफॉर्मेशन आपको प्रोवाइड
कर दिया है तो तो मैं आपको फिर से बता
देता हूं कि अगर यह सही है कि अगर आपको
नोट्स एक्सेस करने हैं तो क्या करना है गो
टू यो डेनिस अकेडमी डेनिस पर जाना है आपको
सिंपली वहां पर क्या करना है गो टू अकेडमी
अकेडमी पेज एंड देन डीसी जेएसपी
प्रैक्टिकल यहां पर आपको क्लिक करना है पे
₹ यहां पर आपको क्या करना है सारे के सारे
जितने भी नोट्स हैं वो सारे के सारे यहीं
पर अपलोड किए जाएंगे आपके और यहां से आपको
सर्टिफिकेट भी मिलेगा तो जिसने भी जवाइन
नहीं किया है प्लीज जवाइन कर लीजिए ₹ कुछ
नहीं होते ना तो इसमें आप हमें दे रहे ना
हमारी जेब में आ र है बस ये आपके बेनिफिट
के लिए है वेरिफिकेशन पर्पस के लिए है और
जब मैं बात कर रहा था लिन प्रोफाइल की
लिंकन प्रोफाइल प मैं सब आपको यह शेयर
करूंगा
कि यह जो चैप्टर था यह चैप्टर में
क्या-क्या पढ़ाया गया था ओके यस
इंफॉर्मेशन वहां पर अवेलेबल रहेगी क्योंकि
वहां पर मेरे को शायद लिंक दिन प्रोफाइल प
एक मैसेज था समथिंग लाइक दैट कि कुछ
एग्जैक्ट की वहां पर मतलब कि थोड़ा
कंफ्यूजन जो हमारे जो नोट्स हैं इनको क्या
किया कुछ लोगों ने जैसे मैंने नोट्स शेयर
किए थे तो मेरे पास कुछ थोड़ी देर पहले
मेल आया तो उसन नोट को किसी ने क्या किया
थोड़े से एडिट किए और एडिट करने के बाद
क्या किया उनको खुद से सेल कर रहे हैं या
खुद से रीयूज कर रहे हैं डेनेस वर्ड को
मिटा के व करके तो प्राइवेसी कंसर्न की
वजह से मैंने अभी नोट्स शेयर करना बंद कर
रहा हूं वहां पर लिंक दिन पर लेकिन लिंक
दिन पे आप क्या कर सकते हैं वहां पर मुझे
फॉलो कीजिए वहां पर हर क्लास की एलिटी
रहेगी और लिंक दिन पे आप चाहो तो कमेंट
बता सकते हो कि क्या हमने क्या-क्या सीखा
है तो उससे क्या है कि दोनों को फायदा
होगा क्योंकि वहां पर भी अपडेट आते रहेंगे
कि कौन सी क्लास होगी कौन सी नहीं होगी तो
यह छोटा सा कंफ्यूजन था शायद आप लोगों अभी
दूर हो गया
होगा अगर किसी को कोई डाउट है तो प्लीज
मुझसे पूछ सकते हैं और सेशन को हम इधर ही
एंड करेंगे फिर
मेरी लिंक दिन की प्रोफाइल नहीं मिली क्या
ओके
मे भी दिस विल बी माय प्रोफाइल य
रहा
नाउ ब भी दिस इ द प्रोफाइल लिंक दिन में
मैं खुद नया
हूं नाओ में मैं आपको प्रोवाइड कर दूं
जैसे मुझे एक बार थोड़ा सा मिलेगा हिंट तो
मुझे एक बार फाइंड आउट करनी पड़ेगी
प्रोफाइल कहां पर मिलेगी मुझे मेरी
प्रोफाइल क्योंकि आई एम आल्सो न्यू फॉर
लिंकडन
चलो बताइए कोई भी डाउट है किसी का क्लास
रिलेटेड प्लीज मुझसे पूछ सकता
है बताइए बताइए बताइए पूछिए दे ओनली 27
स्टूडेंट्स तो अगली बार से अगर मेरी क्लास
में 62 स्टूडेंट नहीं हुए तो आई विल नॉट
टेक द क्लास मैं यहीं पर कोर्स को फिनिश
कर दूंगा मुझे फर्क नहीं पड़ता कि कोर्स
मेरा चले या ना चले मेरी प्रोफाइल खराब
होती होने दोय पर बट आई विल स्टॉप द कोर्स
मैं इतनी मेहनत करता हूं बट आप लोगों को
कुछ है नहीं यार इतना तो रिस्पांस दीजिए
ना मैं आप लोग से सिर्फ एक ही रिक्वेस्ट
चाहिए आप लोगों को
कि कि प्लीज आप एक काम कीजिए इसको मैं
आपको इतनी अच्छी क्वालिटी प्रीमियम
क्वालिटी कंटेंट प्रोवाइड करता हूं क्या
आप मेरे लिए इतना नहीं कर सकते कि इसको
मैक्सिमम टू मैक्सिमम शेयर करो और मतलब हर
जगह इसको पहुंचा दो इतना नहीं कर सकते मैं
आप लोगों से कुछ नहीं मांग रहा बस इतना ही
मांग रहा हूं कि बदले में मैं आपको नोट्स
दे रहा हूं आपको गाइडेंस दे रहा हूं आपके
हर मैसेज का रिप्लाई कर रहा हूं आपके
डाउट्स क्लियर कर रहा हूं और आपसे मैं
सिर्फ बदले में इतनी चीज मांग रहा हूं कि
प्लीज आप मैक्सिमम स्टूडेंट तक इसको प्लीज
रेफर कर दीजिए इसको पहुंचा दीजिए सो डट की
ब अटेंड करें लेकिन आप तो डे बाय डे कम
होते जा रहे हो
बग हंटिंग के लिए साइबर एआई तो यह बग
बाउंट की पूरी सीरीज देख लीजिए आपको काफी
कुछ सीखने को मिल
जाएगा बताइए किसी को कोई डाउट है मुझसे
पूछ लीजिए सूरज कुमार पूछ र सर जीरो डे
क्या होता है
अगर हमें मॉड्यूल मेटा स्प्ड फ्रेम
में तो सूरज पहला सवाल आपका जीरो डे का
मैं आपको जवाब दे देता हूं जीरो डे वनटी
होती है जो सबसे पहली बार आपने फाइंड आउट
की है किसी ने फाइंड आउट नहीं की उसको
बोलते हैं जीरो डे वनटी ओके और मैट स्लेट
मॉड्यूल को कैसे यूज करना मेटा फ्रेमवर्क
के अंदर मैं आपको सिखाऊंगा क्योंकि अभी आज
टाइम हो गया था इसलिए
नेक्स्ट क्लास में आपको मैं सिखाऊंगा ठीक
है देन उसके बाद आपने पूछा कि सर एथिकल
हैकर्स और सिक्योरिटी रिसर्च कौन से
सिनेरियो में एक्सप्लोर करते हैं तो व
सारी टेक्निक्स आपको पूरे कोर्स के दौरान
में सिखाऊंगा और आप अगर एक दो घंटे के लिए
आए हो कि सर एक दो घंटे में सब कुछ सीख
लूंगा तो नॉट
पॉसिबल और उसके बाद यस रितेश कोप जपति ने
आपको बता दिया कैसे आपको जवाइन करना
है सर ए पन टेस्टिंग का कोई कोर्स कब तक
आएगा तो जल्दी आपको अनाउंसमेंट देखने को
मिलेगी एड पन टेस्टिंग के बारे में और एक
बैच हो चुका है सेकंड बैच आएगा
जल्दी उसका पेड वर्जन भी अवेलेबल है वहां
पर और भी एडवांस फीचर्स है तो वह
इंडस्ट्री लेवल पर यूज किए जाते हैं
एसके इस कोर्स के बाद आपको क्या करना है
कि इसके बाद मेरा एक और एडवांस कोर्स है
मतलब मेरा नहीं हमारा सबका नितेश सर में
हम सभी जिसको हम डीसीएसपी बोलते हैं डेफ
सर्टिफाइड सिक्योरिटी प्रोफेशनल तो उसमें
थोड़ा सा और कंटेंट ऐड करेंगे तो उसको
कीजिए तो आपको और भी ज्यादा कुछ सीखने को
मिलेगा
तो एनोनिमस भाई आपको पहले विंडोज की नॉलेज
तो होनी
चाहिए आपको विंडोज की काफी भर भर के नॉलेज
होनी चाहिए तभी आप मैनुअल न व नेबल बना
सकते
हो और कोई किसी और कोई सवाल
किसी का और कोई सवाल
बताइए पूछ सकता
है थैंक यू
प्रणय यहां पर कितने लोग जवाइन कर
लिया जो लिंक मैंने आपको बताया
था नोट के
लिए नहीं भाई स्पैमिंग कर दोगे मेरे नंबर
की मैं नहीं
दूंगा गुड दीपांशु
गुड गुड परने
एसके कर लीजिए
जवाइन अच्छा मिलेगा नोट्स उधर ही मिलेंगे
आपको गुड
अखिलेश गुड रितेश
तो मह ब्लैकट वही तो चल रहा है इंटरनल
पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग सिखाओ सर वही चल रहा
है आपका इस इस कोर्स के बाद आपको अगर मैं
कोई भी लैब दे दूंगा ना तो जैसे कि मैं
हैक द बॉक्स से या आपकी बात करें हम चाहे
ट्राई हैक म की बात करें या किसी भी रिसो
से आपको बोला जाए कि यह आपकी एक लैब है आप
इसको सॉल्व कीजिए तो आप कर
लोगे टूल्स टेक्निक्स आपके पास है बस
मेहनत आपको करनी है इट्स माय गारंटी इतनी
गारंटी कोई लेगा मैं ले रहा
हूं बिल्कुल बन सकते हो उमेश
क्या करें सेशन को एंड करते भाई
फिर आप लोगों के सवाल जवाब सवाल तो है
नहीं